This is a smart list. Coming right at you. Oh, that's genius. Yes, wonderful. And cue the music. Lattice. Smart. Lattice. Smart. Lattice.
这是一个智能列表。马上就来。哦，真是天才。是的，太棒了。音乐起。Lattice。智能。Lattice。智能。Lattice。
Jason, hi, sorry, so stressful. That is so stressful. We have sometimes, every once in a while, we'll have tech difficulties. Yeah, listener, we apologize if we were late today. Well, would we have been late with the listener? How does it work? Not like that.
杰森，嗨，抱歉，太紧张了。那真是太紧张了。我们有时，偶尔会遇到技术故障。是的，听众朋友们，如果我们今天迟到了，我们深表歉意。好吧，我们会因为听众而迟到吗？这是怎么运作的？不是那样的。
But it's a good, I get where you're going with it. And yeah, more an apology to our special guest. Yeah, I'm so sorry, special guest. Who Sean and I don't know who it is yet. Yeah, so sorry. Well, let me tell you something, Will. You're going to be mortified when you realize that you've embarrassed yourself. You and your silly podcast operation have embarrassed yourself in front of this guest.
但这是一个好的，我明白你的意思。是的，更多的是向我们的特别嘉宾道歉。是的，我很抱歉，特别嘉宾。肖恩和我还不知道是谁。是的，太抱歉了。好吧，让我告诉你一件事，威尔。当你意识到你让自己出丑时，你会感到非常羞愧。你和你那愚蠢的播客操作在嘉宾面前让自己出丑了。
Why? How did I do it? I'm not in charge of Sean. Yeah, but you're going to feel the most embarrassment because... No, no, no. That should be... It's not even... I mentioned Scottie. This one's firmly on Scottie, and I feel like this is his department, he's in the tech department over at their house, and he's head of IT and he fucked up. I know nothing, I know nothing.
为什么？我怎么做到的？我不负责肖恩。是的，但你会感到最尴尬，因为……不，不，不。那应该是……这甚至不是……我提到了斯科蒂。这完全是斯科蒂的责任，我觉得这是他的部门，他在他们那边的技术部门，他是IT主管，他搞砸了。我什么都不知道，我什么都不知道。
I hand him my iPhone. Where is Scottie today, what's his excuse? He's working in the back in his little studio. So he's doing his things instead of doing your things. That's right. There's the problem. Priorities have shifted. Yeah, they have shifted.
我把我的iPhone交给他。斯科蒂今天在哪，他有什么借口？他在后面的小工作室里工作。所以他在做他的事情，而不是做你的事情。没错。问题就在这。优先级已经转移了。是的，已经转移了。
We should bring him in front of the council. Yeah. And he probably can't step away from those duties for 10 minutes, can he? No, no, he can't. Yeah. Yeah. It'd be the 12 steps that it takes him to walk
我们应该把他带到委员会面前。是的。他可能无法离开那些职责10分钟，对吧？不，不，他不能。是的。是的。那将是他走那12步的距离
from the back to the front. By the way, Jay, I didn't know that Franny was in 9 to 5. Yes, yes. I would have completely seen that. Oh my God, you would have loved it. Yes, so Franny, Tracy, my 17-year-old, she was in a musical last week at her school. She was incredible, I can say.
从后面走到前面。顺便说一句，杰伊，我不知道弗兰妮演了《朝九晚五》。是的，是的。我完全会去看那个。哦，天哪，你会喜欢的。是的，弗兰妮，特蕾西，我17岁的女儿，她上周在学校演了一部音乐剧。我可以说是令人难以置信。
I heard she was great, yeah. Yeah, and I'm just so, so proud. And she seems to, unfortunately, have been bitten by the actor bug, the performance bug, the audience bug, the whole thing. I bet. And so, you know, we're gonna have to manage that. I'm obviously gonna support her.
我听说她很棒，是的。是的，我真的，真的非常骄傲。不幸的是，她似乎被演员虫、表演虫、观众虫咬了一口，整个事情。我敢打赌。所以，你知道，我们将不得不管理这一点。我显然会支持她。
No, I mean, I've tried. I heard she played Roz, right? Did she sing the theme song, like the title song? As part of the ensemble, yes. It was, now, 9 to 5 was on Broadway at one point, was it not? Correct, yes. It, Nine to Five was on Broadway at one point, was it not? Correct, yes, uh-huh. It seemed like it's a great show.
不，我是说，我试过了。我听说她演了罗兹，对吧？她唱了主题曲，就像标题曲吗？作为合唱团的一部分，是的。现在，《朝九晚五》曾经在百老汇上演过，不是吗？没错，是的。《朝九晚五》曾经在百老汇上演过，不是吗？没错，是的，嗯哼。这看起来是一场很棒的演出。
Yeah, I heard it's really good. The whole tumble out of bed, stumble to the kitchen, pour myself a cup of ambition, yawn and stretch and try to come alive. Oh, you know the song. I've never seen Jason. I saw it three times last week. And Maple, our 12 year old,
是的，我听说真的很棒。整个“滚下床，跌跌撞撞走进厨房，给自己倒一杯雄心壮志，打个哈欠，伸个懒腰，试着活过来”。哦，你知道这首歌。我从来没见过杰森。我上周看了三次。还有梅普尔，我们12岁的孩子，
she was maybe even more obsessed by the whole experience. Yes, she told me. There are two on the loading dock. Here it comes, Hollywood Better Get Ready. Maple liked it a lot too, huh? Yeah, she loved it. She's gonna get into theater when she gets to the upper school.
她可能对整个体验更加着迷。是的，她告诉过我。装卸码头有两个。它来了，好莱坞最好准备好。梅普尔也很喜欢它，对吧？是的，她很喜欢。当她上高中时，她会进入戏剧界。
Really? She says she's not interested in the tech part at all. Yeah, she doesn't wanna get her hands dirty building sets and light cues and stuff like that. She just wants a spotlight. But it was very, very cool. I loved it. It's fun to watch that, right?
真的吗？她说她对技术部分一点也不感兴趣。是的，她不想弄脏手去搭建布景和灯光提示之类的东西。她只想要聚光灯。但这非常，非常酷。我很喜欢。看那个很有趣，对吧？
Now, Jay, the painting behind you, you painted that or you bought that? It seems like to watch that. The painting behind you, you painted that or you bought that or? It seems like it's some, like I would, I know, it's a little frame heavy left. Let me adjust my composition there. Let's do that. There we go. Let's go me and.
现在，杰伊，你身后的那幅画，是你画的还是买的？看起来像是看那个。你身后的那幅画，是你画的还是买的，或者？看起来像是某种，就像我会，我知道，它有点左重。让我调整一下我的构图。我们这样做吧。好了。让我们去我和。
Oh, look at that nice kitchenette. It looks like flowers, but it's actually a broom. All right, sorry listener. You know what, it's been too long now. We've kept our guest waiting because of Scotty ignoring you, Sean. So let me do my best. Sean, just have a deep, deep pool of milk though
哦，看那个漂亮的小厨房。看起来像花，但实际上是一把扫帚。好吧，抱歉听众。你知道吗，现在时间太长了。因为斯科蒂无视你，肖恩，我们让嘉宾久等了。所以让我尽力而为。肖恩，虽然喝一大杯牛奶
before we get the guest out here. Yeah, have a good one. He truly did, listener. Just a big, hard shot of milk. So this is a fella that, Will would probably do a better job introducing this guy. And he probably will be driving this interview much more than me, although I am a huge fan of his as well.
在我们让嘉宾出来之前。是的，祝你愉快。他确实做到了，听众。就是一大杯硬牛奶。所以这是一个家伙，威尔可能在介绍这个家伙方面做得更好。而且他可能比我更多地推动这次采访，尽管我也是他的超级粉丝。
But I can't really elaborate with one of my incredible introductions like I usually do. When do you do those? But I will. Sean, what did he say? So I will say that, well, let me, I'm gonna say some things here, and Willie as soon as you guess it you can go ahead And introduce them. All right. All right
但我不能像往常那样用我不可思议的介绍来详细说明。你什么时候做那些？但我会。肖恩，他说了什么？所以我说，好吧，让我，我要在这里说一些事情，威利，一旦你猜到了，你就可以继续介绍他们。好的。好的
This guy this stud this world famous athlete in the room played for Manchester United Real Madrid AC Milan LA-Germain, and the England National Team. David Beckham, are you kidding me? David Beckham, get out here. What? No way!
这个家伙，这个种马，这个世界著名的运动员在房间里，为曼联、皇家马德里、AC米兰、巴黎圣日耳曼和英格兰国家队效力。大卫·贝克汉姆，你在开玩笑吗？大卫·贝克汉姆，出来吧。什么？不会吧！
Okay? Oh my God. No, I'm not joking. You're welcome, Will. I'm joking. It's not even your birthday. Wait, I'm so sorry for keeping you waiting. Don't worry.
好吗？哦，天哪。不，我不是在开玩笑。不客气，威尔。我在开玩笑。甚至不是你的生日。等等，我很抱歉让你久等了。别担心。
Shut up, Sean. It doesn't have damage already. You't worry. Shut up, Sean. You've done enough damage already. You shut your mouth. David, thank you for joining us. It's a pleasure. Thank you for having me on. This is so exciting to me
闭嘴，肖恩。它已经没有损坏了。你别担心。闭嘴，肖恩。你已经造成了足够的破坏。你闭嘴。大卫，谢谢你加入我们。这是我的荣幸。谢谢你邀请我。这对我来说太令人兴奋了
because I knew nothing about football, soccer. Watched the documentary. It's all I can stop talking about. It was incredible. I can't stop talking about it. It was incredible. We're gonna get to that. And the fact that you had to spend so much time with Fisher Stevens shows what great resolve
因为我对足球一无所知。看了纪录片。我一直在谈论它。这太不可思议了。我无法停止谈论它。这太不可思议了。我们会谈到那个。而且你不得不花这么多时间与费舍尔·史蒂文斯在一起，这表明你作为一个人有多大的决心
you have as a human being. Well... Fisher's our friend. He's amazing. He's amazing. It took us a while to find him as a director. You know, I looked for a long time for the right person to help me tell the story.
你拥有。好吧……费舍尔是我们的朋友。他很棒。他很棒。我们花了一段时间才找到他作为导演。你知道，我找了很长时间才找到合适的人来帮助我讲述这个故事。
And the moment I met him, I knew he was firstly, unfortunately, he was a Liverpool fan, like you will, but other than that, he's a great guy. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. David, what an absolute thrill to meet you, my friend. This is so cool. I'm such a massive fan. First of all, where are we finding you?
当我见到他的那一刻，我就知道他首先，不幸的是，他是一个利物浦球迷，就像你威尔一样，但除此之外，他是一个很棒的人。是的，是的，是的，是的。大卫，见到你真是太激动了，我的朋友。这太酷了。我是你的超级粉丝。首先，我们在哪里找到你？
I'm actually in London okay I'm just I've been in the office all day and then I have a premiere of a Friends series on Netflix tonight so I'm I'm heading there after after here but that's why I've got a shirt and tie on yeah I was gonna say now let me guess is this is or is this for Ripley? This is Guy Ritchie's series tonight. So he's doing the Gentleman series. I've seen the movie, but the series he's been working on for a while, so I'm heading there tonight.
我实际上在伦敦，好的，我整天都在办公室，然后我今晚在Netflix上有一个系列剧的首映式，所以我在这里之后就要去那里，但这就是为什么我穿了衬衫和领带，是的，我正要说，现在让我猜猜，这是为了《雷普利》吗？这是盖·里奇今晚的系列剧。所以他正在做《绅士》系列。我看过电影，但他一直在制作这个系列，所以我今晚要去那里。
I think he's a great director. Well, it's no surprise, and you made an excuse for wearing a shirt and tie, but you always look really, really well turned out. Sorry you're not good looking. He's working on it. He's trying to distract from his ugly looks by dressing up a bit.
我认为他是一位伟大的导演。好吧，这并不奇怪，你为穿衬衫和领带找了借口，但你看起来总是非常，非常得体。抱歉你长得不好看。他正在努力。他正试图通过稍微打扮一下来分散人们对他丑陋外表的注意力。
No, but I was gonna say. We do what we can. You do what you can. You follow, that is something that has been a trademark of yours. You've always been kind of into style and into fashion and that comes through in the doc, series about your life.
不，但我正要说。我们尽力而为。你尽力而为。你跟随，那是你的标志之一。你一直对风格和时尚很感兴趣，这在关于你生活的纪录片系列中体现了出来。
Do you feel pressure in that? I always want to know, do you feel pressure in that way because you've set this standard? Like you're like, oh shit, I better look good when I go to the store. Yes, to be honest, not at all. I never feel pressure on that side. I think my wife added to the fashion side of my life when
你对此感到压力吗？我一直想知道，你是否在那方面感到压力，因为你设定了这个标准？就像你觉得，哦该死，我去商店时最好看起来不错。是的，说实话，一点也不。我从来没有在那方面感到压力。我认为我妻子在我生命中的时尚方面增加了
we met 27 years ago. But even before then, you know, I was always into fashion even at eight years old when I tell the story about when I was a page boy at one of our friends weddings, my mum's friend's wedding. And she asked me if I wanted to wear a suit or I wanted to wear tights and a pair of ballet shoes, and I chose the tights and ballet shoes. So, in all honesty, I never feel pressure. I enjoy wearing suits, I enjoy wearing casual clothes, but I never feel the pressure to look in any certain way. But so you have a position somewhere in the English government
我们27年前相遇时。但即使在那之前，你知道，我一直对时尚很感兴趣，甚至在八岁时，当我讲述我在我们朋友的婚礼上做花童的故事时，我妈妈朋友的婚礼。她问我想穿西装还是想穿紧身裤和一双芭蕾舞鞋，我选择了紧身裤和芭蕾舞鞋。所以，老实说，我从来没有感到压力。我喜欢穿西装，我喜欢穿休闲装，但我从来没有感到必须以某种方式看起来的压力。但你在英国政府的某个地方有一个职位
or somehow with the fashion industry. I should have this and I'm looking for it. I don't have it here. Great research. Yeah, it's not great over here. Sorry, David. But can you fill in where my dumbness is taking over? Yeah, I do a lot for the Fashion Council, which they made me-
或者以某种方式与时尚界有关。我应该有这个，我正在找它。我这里没有。伟大的研究。是的，这里不太好。抱歉，大卫。但你能填补我的愚蠢正在接管的地方吗？是的，我为时尚委员会做了很多工作，他们让我-
Sounds like the Ministry of Magic. They kind of made me an ambassador of the Fashion Council. And it was something that I was quite surprised about, but in all honesty, it's something that I've loved to be part of because it's about the new generation and the next generation of talented young designers. And that's what I love doing. The work that I do on the charity side, the work that I've done on the soccer side over the years,
听起来像魔法部。他们让我成为了时尚委员会的大使。这让我感到非常惊讶，但老实说，这是我喜欢参与的事情，因为它关乎新一代和下一代有才华的年轻设计师。这就是我喜欢做的事情。多年来我在慈善方面所做的工作，我在足球方面所做的工作，
it's all about the young talent and bringing them through. It's one of the reasons why I started the team in Miami, because I was excited about the talented players that we have in Florida, in South Florida, and obviously in Miami, and that excited me more than anything. So, you know, stepping into the fashion world in that way was exciting for me.
这一切都是关于年轻人才并把他们带出来。这也是我开始迈阿密球队的原因之一，因为我对我们在佛罗里达、南佛罗里达，显然在迈阿密拥有的天才球员感到兴奋，这比什么都让我兴奋。所以，你知道，以那种方式进入时尚界对我来说很令人兴奋。
Well, here's the thing about fashion, because to me. Oh go ahead, yeah, let's hear it from the expert. Everyone's been dying to hear. So just, when you tie the baseball cap into the t-shirt, tell us what the process is. Definitely interrupt David Beckham to get your opinion on fashion, go ahead. No, but my thing is like, Scotty always,
好吧，这就是关于时尚的事情，因为对我来说。哦，继续，是的，让我们听听专家的意见。每个人都渴望听到。所以，当你把棒球帽系在T恤上时，告诉我们过程是什么。一定要打断大卫·贝克汉姆来发表你对时尚的看法，继续。不，但我的事情是，斯科蒂总是，
my husband Scotty always wishes I, Another fashion firestorm. Always wishes I would dress better, right? Like, he's like, are you really gonna walk out of the house looking like that, can't you just put some nice pants and nice shirt? And I was like, you know, the looseness of a t-shirt and the looseness of, it's more comfortable to me. Yeah, that's what it is, and to me, comfort was like, you know, the looseness of a t-shirt and the looseness of, like, it's more comfortable.
我丈夫斯科蒂总是希望我，又一场时尚风暴。总是希望我穿得更好，对吧？就像，他会说，你真的要那样走出家门吗，你不能穿一些漂亮的裤子和漂亮的衬衫吗？我说，你知道，T恤的宽松和，对我来说更舒服。是的，就是这样，对我来说，舒适就像，你知道，T恤的宽松和，就像，它更舒服。
To me, like, yeah, that's what it is. And to me, comfort is like, I don't like dressing in a shirt and a tie, because it's so restricting and the pants are tight and the tuxedo, like, and you enjoy that? Well, if it fits right, if it fits right, then it's comfortable. So most of the time it does.
对我来说，就像，是的，就是这样。对我来说，舒适就像，我不喜欢穿衬衫和领带，因为它太束缚了，裤子很紧，燕尾服，就像，你喜欢那样？好吧，如果它合身，如果它合身，那么它就很舒服。所以大多数时候它确实如此。
So I feel okay doing that. But I, you know. But most of the day you'd like to be in sweats in a t-shirt. Absolutely. Or jeans in a t-shirt. Yeah, of course. Now can I ask you David, do you like a little bit of stretch in your jeans?
所以我这样做感觉还可以。但我，你知道。但一天中大部分时间你都想穿运动裤和T恤。绝对。或者牛仔裤和T恤。是的，当然。现在我可以问你大卫，你喜欢牛仔裤里有一点弹性吗？
I do. I do. It's nice to have a little bit of stretch in the jeans. I get a lot of heat for the stretch I prefer in my jeans. But you know, us athletes, David, we've got nice-sized legs and a real motor behind us. And so we need some room when we sit down. We need room in our jeans. I agree.
我喜欢。我喜欢。牛仔裤里有一点弹性很好。我因为我牛仔裤里偏好的弹性而受到很多批评。但你知道，我们运动员，大卫，我们有漂亮的腿和我们身后的真正引擎。所以当我们坐下时，我们需要一些空间。我们需要牛仔裤里的空间。我同意。
Jason's a little different from you, David, in that he's got the kind of thighs that are made for playing video games. You know what I mean? It looks like he's been sitting in... He's got atrophied limbs. Well, to be honest, I was a fan of Ozark, so I saw those thighs quite a lot of times.
杰森和你有点不同，大卫，因为他有那种为玩电子游戏而生的大腿。你知道我的意思吗？看起来他一直坐在……他有萎缩的四肢。好吧，说实话，我是《黑钱胜地》的粉丝，所以我看了很多次那些大腿。
Oh, you. This is, take your time through this section, David. They look good, they look good. Thank you. He's a very handsome boy. I'm shy. To wrap up the fashion side of it, I'm curious, Will, I'm curious if you like going to these fashion shows.
哦，你。这是，慢慢通过这一部分，大卫。它们看起来不错，它们看起来不错。谢谢。他是一个非常英俊的男孩。我很害羞。为了总结时尚方面，我很好奇，威尔，我很好奇你是否喜欢去这些时装秀。
Do you like sitting front row and seeing all the fashion forward stuff? To be honest, I very rarely go to the shows other than my wife's show. You know, I've gone to a couple of the shows over the years, but I don't go to as many as people think I do. But the ones that I have to go to now, and I want to go to, obviously, are my wife's ones.
你喜欢坐在前排看所有时尚前沿的东西吗？说实话，除了我妻子的秀，我很少去秀场。你知道，多年来我去过几次秀，但我去得没有人们想象的那么多。但我现在必须去，而且我想去的，显然是我妻子的那些。
So I enjoy that. Does she make men's clothing? She doesn't yet. She made me a pair of jeans, actually. She should send you a pair and they fit well. So she made me a pair of jeans the other day. So we'll see. I don't know what she's going to go into next,
所以我很享受。她做男装吗？她还没有。实际上，她给我做了一条牛仔裤。她应该寄给你一条，它们很合身。所以她前几天给我做了一条牛仔裤。所以我们走着瞧。我不知道她接下来会进入什么领域，
but she's doing very well. She's a very hardworking woman. So yeah, we'll see. I don't know what she's gonna go into next, but she's doing very well. She's a very hardworking woman, so, uh, yeah, we'll see. She's always looking for new projects. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, I think I saw a video of you at the show the other day, and she came over and gave you a big kiss, right? Well, she gave me a big kiss because obviously it was quite an emotional one for her.
但她做得很好。她是一个非常勤奋的女人。所以是的，我们走着瞧。我不知道她接下来会进入什么领域，但她做得很好。她是一个非常勤奋的女人，所以，呃，是的，我们走着瞧。她一直在寻找新的项目。是的，是的。是的，我想我前几天在秀场上看到了你的视频，她走过来给了你一个大吻，对吧？好吧，她给了我一个大吻，因为显然这对她来说是一个非常感人的时刻。
These shows are always emotional for obviously the work that she puts in, and then it's over in like eight minutes. That's what I'm saying. So, yeah. So I got invited to an Armani one in Milan. Yeah. So I flew halfway across the world,
这些秀总是很感人，显然是因为她投入的工作，然后在大约八分钟内就结束了。这就是我所说的。所以，是的。所以我被邀请参加米兰的阿玛尼秀。是的。所以我飞了半个世界，
because I'd never been to a fashion show. Who's male were you accidentally getting that week? Fuck. So we fly around, halfway around the world, I go sit in the front row of this Armani fashion show, it's two minutes long. Yeah, I know, I know. I'm like, what?
因为我从来没去过时装秀。你那周意外得到了谁的男性？该死。所以我们飞来飞去，飞了半个世界，我去坐在阿玛尼时装秀的前排，只有两分钟长。是的，我知道，我知道。我心想，什么？
It is amazing, but she was emotional because she's also got a broken foot at the moment. Oh, yes. So she broke her foot. Funny story, we went skiing. She came for two days. She kept on saying, I'm not gonna ski, I'm not gonna ski because I've got too much going on.
这很神奇，但她很感人，因为她目前脚也骨折了。哦，是的。所以她脚骨折了。有趣的故事，我们去滑雪了。她来了两天。她一直说，我不滑雪，我不滑雪，因为我有太多事情要忙。
So she then went home after two days, left me with all the kids. She was stretching in the gym. And by the way, Victoria is the biggest fan of the podcast, by the way. Is she? Oh no way. She's so sweet. And we love her. This morning, I don't think I've actually never had so many texts from her during the day on the lead up to this. She actually texts me at three o'clock. She was like, have you done the podcast yet?
所以她在两天后回家了，留下了我和所有的孩子。她在健身房拉伸。顺便说一句，维多利亚是这个播客的超级粉丝，顺便说一句。她是吗？哦，不会吧。她太甜了。我们爱她。今天早上，我想我从来没有在这一天的准备过程中收到过她这么多短信。她实际上在三点钟给我发短信。她说，你做完播客了吗？
And I was like, no. And then this morning at breakfast, she was like, okay, I'm going to give you some pointers. Don't try and be funny. She said, you guys usually focus on actors and not so much athletes. Obviously, I've listened to a few of the athletes you've had on. But she was like, don't talk too much about soccer because these guys are intelligent. The people that are listening to these podcasts are people like me, she said.
我说，没有。然后今天早上在早餐时，她说，好吧，我要给你一些建议。不要试图变得有趣。她说，你们通常关注演员，而不是那么多运动员。显然，我听过你们请过的一些运动员。但她说，不要谈论太多足球，因为这些人很聪明。听这些播客的人是像我这样的人，她说。
So she said, I don't want to listen to soccer the whole way through this. So, you know. Right, right. We're gonna cover a little bit of it and Tracy's just gonna have to deal with it. Believe me, first of all, let's say that we're fans of Victoria's. Yeah, huge, huge, huge.
所以她说，我不想在整个过程中听足球。所以，你知道。对，对。我们会谈论一点，特蕾西将不得不处理它。相信我，首先，让我们说我们是维多利亚的粉丝。是的，巨大，巨大，巨大。
First and foremost, and so hello, Victoria. I'm a huge fan, yeah. Secondly, I'm sorry to say that when she says we're intelligent, she must be talking about a different podcast. Thirdly, we're gonna talk about football, AKA soccer, which by the way, we covered this. Soccer is actually an English term,
首先，你好，维多利亚。我是超级粉丝，是的。其次，我很抱歉地说，当她说我们很聪明时，她一定是在谈论另一个播客。第三，我们将谈论足球，也就是足球，顺便说一句，我们涵盖了这个。足球实际上是一个英语术语，
everybody thinks it's an American term, but you David probably know. Soccer is an abbreviation of association football, and they called it Soc-er, right David? Yep, that's true. No, I didn't know that. Yeah, it's not American. So, David, so let's get into it. Where did's get where did the ER come from song like the way they do
每个人都认为这是一个美国术语，但你大卫可能知道。足球是协会足球的缩写，他们称之为Soc-er，对吧大卫？是的，那是真的。不，我不知道。是的，这不是美国的。所以，大卫，让我们进入它。ER是从哪里来的，像他们做的那样
rugby and they call it rugger it was the same idea they was kind of right David by the way this is the first time I'm hearing this so I'm just agreeing with you will it's just oh yeah it's true so the way that's amazing rugby and they and they call that rugger is like a sort of a slangy version and soccer or football is called association football to distinguish it from rugby. It's called association football and then they just took the sock from association and called it soccer. Anyway. Wow. I think we just ran out of time. Yeah, thanks for joining us David. David, so listen, so you started playing football
橄榄球，他们称之为rugger，这是同样的想法，他们有点对，大卫，顺便说一句，这是我第一次听到这个，所以我只是同意你威尔，这只是哦是的，这是真的，所以那种方式太神奇了，橄榄球，他们称之为rugger，就像一种俚语版本，足球或足球被称为协会足球，以区别于橄榄球。它被称为协会足球，然后他们只是从协会中取了sock，称之为soccer。无论如何。哇。我想我们时间到了。是的，谢谢你加入我们大卫。大卫，所以听着，所以你开始踢足球
when you were a kid and your dad, and I love that they cover this in the documentary, your dad was a huge Man U fan growing up. And then you go and become one of the great Man U players, when you say Manchester United, you think David Beckham. But you started the Man U Academy as a little kid, right? Well, I'm an East End boy, so I'm from the East End of London.
当你还是个孩子的时候，你爸爸，我喜欢他们在纪录片中涵盖这一点，你爸爸从小就是曼联的超级粉丝。然后你成为伟大的曼联球员之一，当你提到曼联时，你会想到大卫·贝克汉姆。但你从小就进入了曼联学院，对吧？好吧，我是东区男孩，所以我来自伦敦东区。
And obviously I started actually at Tottenham's Academy and Arsenal's Academy as a young kid. Oh. So. What about West Ham? Were you? Yeah, West Ham wanted me to go down and train with them, but I was obviously, at that point,
显然我实际上是作为一个小孩子在托特纳姆学院和阿森纳学院开始的。哦。所以。西汉姆呢？你是吗？是的，西汉姆想让我下去和他们一起训练，但我显然，在那个时候，
I was having to decide between Arsenal and Tottenham. My grandfather was a season ticket holder for 50 years at Spurs at Tottenham, so I decided to go with Tottenham. So I spent a couple of years training at Tottenham, till I was 12 years old, and then Manchester United noticed me down in London. They invited me up to Manchester,
我必须在阿森纳和托特纳姆之间做出决定。我祖父在托特纳姆热刺队做了50年的季票持有者，所以我决定去托特纳姆。所以我花了几年时间在托特纳姆训练，直到我12岁，然后曼联在伦敦注意到了我。他们邀请我去曼彻斯特，
and that's when it all started, and I moved up to Manchester when I was 15. Wow. And let me bring Sean into the conversation. Sean, when David said that he's an East End boy, did you start humming Pet Shop Boys to yourself? Absolutely. Don't lie.
那就是一切开始的时候，我在15岁时搬到了曼彻斯特。哇。让我把肖恩带入对话。肖恩，当大卫说他是东区男孩时，你开始对自己哼唱宠物店男孩了吗？绝对。别撒谎。
Yeah, me too. I love that song. Wait, but I have a question about the doc, because now I know everything about you, and I'm obsessed with you like the west of the world. And so, because- Like the west of the world? By the way, are you just gonna go off topic
是的，我也是。我喜欢那首歌。等等，但我有一个关于纪录片的问题，因为现在我知道关于你的一切，我像世界西部一样迷恋你。所以因为- 像世界西部一样？顺便说一句，你只是要偏离主题吗
because we're just getting on- No, no, it's about soccer. It's about football. So because in the documentary, the thing that blew my mind was when the whole country turned on you in that moment, that right in the moment in the documentary, and the moment in your career.
因为我们只是在- 不，不，这是关于足球。这是关于足球。所以因为在纪录片中，让我震惊的事情是整个国家在那个时刻，就在纪录片中的那个时刻，以及你职业生涯中的那个时刻背叛了你。
And I was at home not knowing anything, not involved with the ins and outs of the crowd and the game and everything like that. I'm going, why are they booing the greatest player? They should be supporting you. So what is the mob mentality of turning on the best player in England? In the world?
我当时在家，什么都不知道，没有参与人群和比赛的内幕等等。我心想，他们为什么要嘘最伟大的球员？他们应该支持你。那么，背叛英格兰最好的球员的暴民心态是什么？在世界上？
I think the English have always had that mentality of build someone up, knock them down, and then watch them get out of that again. And once they get out of that, there's a lot more respect there. But I think, you know, I made a mistake in 1998 with the red card and I owned up to that mistake and then I had to spend the next three or four years trying to get through these games and the seasons and the abuse that I was getting. But I think, to your point, Sean, that I think one of the things that came out
我认为英国人一直有那种建立某人，击倒他们，然后看着他们再次摆脱那种心态。一旦他们摆脱了这一点，就会有更多的尊重。但我认为，你知道，我在1998年犯了一个红牌错误，我承认了那个错误，然后我不得不花接下来的三四年时间试图度过这些比赛和赛季以及我所受到的虐待。但我认为，就你的观点而言，肖恩，我认为纪录片中出现的一件事是，美国每个人都记得我为银河队效力。他们记得我为我的国家效力，也记得我效力过的其他球队，但他们不知道我所经历的故事。所以每次我在迈阿密、洛杉矶、纽约或美国的某个地方，人们都会走过来，就像，我们不知道那个故事。
of the documentary is the fact that everyone in America remembers me playing for the Galaxy. They remember me playing for my country and also other teams that I played for, but they didn't know the story of what I'd gone through. And so every time that I'm in Miami or LA or New York or somewhere in the US, people come up to me and were like, we didn't know that story.
就像你刚才说的那样，我想对很多人来说，这部纪录片提醒了他们首先它有多糟糕，有时也让人们真正了解这个故事。所以谈论它实际上相当困难。它人性化了，你知道，看，你在某一点上，你知道这一点大卫，当然你们知道这一点，程度不同，不像大卫那样，但你成为你是一个人，但公众以某种方式拥有你，他们拥有这个关于你的想法，你为英格兰效力，你担任英格兰队长，他们以某种方式在他们的脑海中拥有你，所以如果你以他们感知的任何方式搞砸了，他们就像，嘿伙计，你不能，你不能犯错。你不能成为人类。而且太该死的，哦呜呜大卫，哦你很有钱，很有名。就像，好吧，我仍然是一个早上醒来并犯错的人。是的，而且你无法隐藏，我敢打赌，对吧？
Like, just like you've said, and I suppose for a lot of people, the documentary was a reminder of firstly how bad it was and sometimes also for people to actually know the story. So it was it was quite hard talking for it actually. It humanizes and you know look you at a certain point you and you know this David and certainly you guys know this to a different degree not the same way that David does but you become you are your own person but then the public owns you in a way they own this idea of you and you play for you play
我的意思是，与美国相比，英格兰是一个如此小的地方。没有一个角落你可以去而不必准备好面对对抗或奉承。我知道伦敦有几个角落我可以给你看。继续。我们马上回来。
for England you Captain England you they kind of in their mind they kind of own you so if you fuck up in whatever way that they perceive they're like hey man you go you don't get to you don't get to make mistakes. You don't get to be human. And too fucking, oh boo hoo David, oh you're rich, famous. And it's like, well I'm still a person who wakes up in the morning and makes mistakes. Yeah, and you can't hide, I'll bet, right?
这个节目由BetterHelp赞助。如果你像我一样处于一段关系中，虽然我的关系非常美好，18年了，但如果你处于一段关系中，我们都会经历一些事情和时候，当你有点压抑一些感觉并把它藏在心里时，但如果你把它藏在心里太久，你以后只会爆发。
I mean, England is such a small place in comparison to America. There's not a corner you can go without having to be ready for either confrontation or adulation. I know a couple corners in London I can show you. Go ahead. We'll be right back.
所以你必须学习如何以一种尊重的态度把事情说出来，这样人们就会听到它，而不是不听到它并反击。我必须通过治疗来学习这一点。因为我们都带着不同的压力源，大的和小的，当我们把它们装在瓶子里时，它会开始对我们产生负面影响。治疗是一个安全的空间，可以把事情从你的胸口拿出来
This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. If you're in a relationship like I am, although mine's pretty wonderful, 18 years, but if you're in a relationship and we all go through things and times when you kind of stuff some feelings and you keep it inside, but if you keep it inside too long, you're just gonna blow up later.
并找出如何解决任何让你感到沉重的事情。检查自己并倾听你的身体和思想告诉你的内容很重要。治疗师可以帮助你识别触发因素或倦怠迹象，这样你就能保持与你所需要的联系。如果你正在考虑开始治疗，给BetterHelp一个机会。
So you have to learn how to get things off your chest and in a respectful kind of way so that people will hear it instead of not hearing it and fight back. And I had to learn that through therapy. And because we all carry around different stressors, big and small, when we keep them bottled up, it can start to affect us negatively. Therapy is a safe space to get things off your chest
它完全在线，旨在方便、灵活，并适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，即可与持证治疗师匹配，并随时免费更换治疗师。用BetterHelp把它从你的胸口拿出来。今天访问betterhelp.com slash smartlis，你的第一个月可享受10%的折扣。
and to figure out how to work through whatever's weighing you down. It's important to check in with yourself and listen to what your body and mind is telling you. A therapist can help you recognize triggers or signs of burnout so you stay in touch with what you need. If you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try.
那是betterhelp，H-E-P点com slash smartlis。Smartlis部分由Audible带给你。Audible让你在一个应用程序中享受所有的音频娱乐。你总能找到你所爱的最好的东西或一些新的发现。他们提供令人难以置信的音频书选择，涵盖各种流派，从畅销书和新发布到名人回忆录、悬疑和惊悚片、励志、健康、商业等等。Audible是你的目的地，提供令人兴奋的音频娱乐，有高度期待的新发布和为每种惊悚片听众推荐的下一个收听建议。
It's entirely online, designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Get it off your chest with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash smartlis today to get 10% off your first month.
作为Audible会员，你可以每月选择一个标题保留，来自整个目录，包括最新的畅销书和新发布。我刚刚发现Audible以最好的方式做惊悚片，最近我刚刚挑选了一本叫《在她死之前》的书，作者是玛丽·伯顿。真的很酷。我会在最后读一下日志行。它说，随着一个疯子的死亡人数上升，侦探丹尼尔·罗尔科夫被卷入了一个变得极其个人的任务中。
That's betterhelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash smartlis. Smartlis is brought to you in part by Audible. Audible lets you enjoy all your audio entertainment in one app. You'll always find the best of what you love or something new to discover. They offer an incredible selection of audiobooks across every genre, from bestsellers and new releases to celebrity memoirs, mysteries and thrillers, motivation, wellness, business and more. Audible is your destination for thrilling audio entertainment with highly anticipated new releases and next listen recommendations for every type of thriller listener.
那种吸引了我，当我开始听的时候，我心想，哦，我得了解更多，我做了，它太好了。新会员可以免费试用Audible 30天。访问audible.com slash smartless，或发短信smartless到500 500。那是audible.com slash smartless，或发短信smartless到500 500，
As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from the entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases. I just discovered Audible does thrillers like in the best way, and recently I just picked out one called Before She Dies by Mary Burton. It's really cool. I'll read the log line here at the end. It says, as a madman's body count rises, Detective Daniel Rolkoff is drawn into a mission that's become terrifyingly personal.
免费试用Audible 30天。Audible.com slash smartlis或发短信smartlis到500 500免费试用Audible 30天audible.com slash smartlis感谢FanDuel支持这一集的smartlis。在NBA和NHL中是赢家通吃的时间，FanDuel给你一个机会带回家一个属于你自己的大胜利。现在，新客户通过任何5美元的获胜投注获得150美元的奖励投注。那是150美元，可以投注在点差、胜负盘、球员道具等等上。投注我能离开多久会很酷
That kind of grabbed me, and when I started listening, I was like, ooh, I gotta learn more, and I did, and it's so good. New members can try Audible free for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless, or text smartless to 500 500. That's audible.com slash smartless, or text smartless to 500 500,
从我们的狗瑞奇身边。因为我们出去吃晚饭，那个时间似乎越来越短，因为我痴迷于他独自一人。人们甚至说，我们应该赌你能在家里外面待多久。我敢打赌你会是一个接近的电话。有人会赢得什么。
to try Audible free for 30 days. Audible.com slash smartlis or text smartlis to 500 500 to try audible free for 30 days audible.com slash smartlis Thank you to FanDuel for supporting this episode of smartlis It's winner take all time in the NBA and NHL and FanDuel is giving you a shot to bring home a big win of your own Right now new customers get $150 in bonus bets with any winning $5 bet. That's 150 bucks to bet on spreads, money lines, player props, and more. It'd be pretty cool to bet on how long I can stay away
访问fandual.com slash smartless，让每一次季后赛投篮都算数。FanDuel，美国第一体育博彩公司。21岁以上，排除适用。查看节目说明以获取完整免责声明。现在回到节目。在这个星球上有没有一个地方你发现你可以去，你可以拥有相对的匿名性，只是四处走动？
from our dog Ricky. Because we go out to dinner, and that time seems to get shorter and shorter because I'm obsessed with him being alone. And people have even said, we should bet on you how long you can last outside of your home. I bet you'd be a close call. Somebody would win something.
好吧，我的一，你知道，我在纪录片中谈到世界杯之后，我去的地方是纽约，因为维多利亚和辣妹组合在那里，她在巡演，我的逃避是纽约。所以我心想，你知道，当时在美国真的没有人真正认识我。他们有点知道我是谁，一些足球迷知道我是谁，但实际上我，是的，但我实际上去那里对我来说是一种逃避。
Visit fandual.com slash smartless and make every playoff shot count. Fandual, America's number one sports book. 21 plus exclusions apply. See show notes for full disclaimer. And now back to the show. Is there a place on the planet that you found that you can go and you can have relative anonymity and just bop around?
但当时媒体太激烈了。你知道，我消失了几个星期，然后当我回来时，我想，我在纪录片中谈到了它，我想，哦，他们会忘记一切，但他们没有。所以当时有点困难。但显然当时和辣妹在一起，他们当时。但显然当时和辣妹在一起，他们
Well, one of my, you know, and I talk about it in a documentary after the World Cup, the place where I went was New York because Victoria was there with the Spice Girls and she was on tour and my escape was New York. So I thought, you know, no one really kind of knew me in the US at that point. They kind of knew who I, some soccer fans knew who I was, but actually me, yeah, but me actually going there was an escape for me.
处于名声的巅峰。所以这有点像两个世界碰撞。我想这就是为什么我可能受到了一些我受到的虐待。老实说，我接受了它，我继续前进，我知道我克服它的唯一方法是更努力地工作，并受到亚历克斯·弗格森爵士的保护。我知道，但你太年轻了，无法经历那个过程并学习那是你摆脱它的方式。就像，你怎么，你太年轻了。
But then the media was so intense at that point. You know, I kind of disappeared for a few weeks, and then by the time I came back, I thought, and I talk about it in the documentary, I thought, oh, they'd have forgot everything, and they didn't. So it was kind of difficult at the time. But obviously being with a Spice Girl at that time, they were at the time. But obviously being with a spy skill at that time, they
知道在英格兰那就是白热化的名声看起来是什么样子，那是你得到的待遇，因此不必太个人化，这只是他们在那边做媒体的方式，这有什么安慰吗？好吧，我想你确实会那样想，直到某一点，但你确实会个人化很多正在发生的事情。你知道，很多正在说的事情，
were at the height of their fame. So it was kind of both worlds colliding. And I think that's why probably I got some of the abuse that I got. And in all honesty, I accepted it, I got on with it, and I knew the only way of me getting over it was working harder and being protected by Sir Alex Ferguson. I know, but you were so young to go through that process and to learn that that's how you get out of it. Like, how do you, you're so young.
但我内心深处知道，尽管我在职业生涯中直到那时还没有经历过任何类似的事情，但我内心深处知道我会没事的。我不知道怎么，我只是知道我在曼联受到保护，我受到亚历克斯·弗格森爵士的保护，但我最感到不安的事情是，我的祖父母受到了影响，我的姐妹们，
Was it comforting at all to know that in England that is kind of what white hot fame looks like, that's the kind of treatment that you get, so therefore need not take it too personally, it's just that's the way they kind of do media there. Well, I suppose you do think like that to a certain point, but you do take a lot of the stuff that is going on personally. You know, a lot of the things that are being said,
我的父母，那是我比什么都感到不安的事情。是的，是的。好吧，让我问你这个，大卫，它出来了，这是我一直有点怀疑的事情，但它在纪录片系列中非常明显地出来了，那就是，那种支持，就像你提到的你的家人，亚历克斯·弗格森爵士，拥有那个核心群体有多少
but I kind of knew deep down, even though I'd not been through anything like that throughout my career up until that point, I knew deep down that I would be okay. I don't know how, I just knew that I was protected at Manchester United, I was protected by Sir Alex Ferguson, but the thing that I got upset mostly about was, my grandparents got affected by it, my sisters,
支持你的人？那是让你度过难关的事情吗？是的，那正是让我度过难关的事情。你知道，显然，我的朋友和我的家人，你知道，我一直有好的、亲密的朋友，我的家人是我不可思议的支持。他们一直都是。嗯，在我的整个职业生涯中，我很幸运
my parents, and that was what upset me more than anything. Yeah, yeah. Well, let me ask you this, David, and it comes out, it's something that I've always sort of suspected, but it comes out glaringly in the docu-series, and is that, how much is that support of, like you mentioned your family, Sir Alex Ferguson, how much was having that core group
即使在，你知道在很小的时候，我的父母支持我所做的一切。但让我度过足球方面难关的一件事是亚历克斯·弗格森爵士的支持，是曼联的支持，可能最大的是我的队友和球迷，因为我去的世界上每一个其他体育场，我都受到了虐待。
of people supporting you? Was that the thing that got you through? Yeah, that was exactly what got me through. You know, obviously, my friends and my family, you know, I've always had good, close friends, and my family are an incredible support for me. They always have been. Um, and I've been lucky with that throughout my whole career,
但在老特拉福德，无论我走到世界各地，我都受到了虐待。但在老特拉福德，你知道，每当我走过去踢角球或任意球时，你知道，整个看台，就像，跳了起来。那是，那是，就像，它就像一个大家庭。所以，你知道，那就是让我。是的，你和你的球员，你和你的队友就像兄弟一样。
even at, you know at a very young age, my parents supported me with whatever I did. But the one thing that got me through on the football side was the support of Sir Alex Ferguson, was the support of Manchester United, and probably the biggest was my teammates and the fans, because every other stadium that I went to around the world, I got abused.
我见过一些不同的东西。我看到了那个。我忘了那是什么了。那是你们五个人在回忆，去……你还记得我们几年前出来吗？92班。92班。是的。
But at Old Trafford, whenever I went to around the world, I got abused. But at Old Trafford, you know, whenever I went over and took a corner or a free kick, you know, the whole stand, like, jumped up. And that was, and that was, like, it was like a big family. So, you know, that's what got me. Yeah, you and your player, you and your teammates were like brothers.
太好了。我几年前在英国时看了那个。我只是喜欢它。显然被称为潜在的史上最伟大的死球踢球者。我的意思是，你有一部以你命名的电影，本，就像，回到……是的，太酷了。这太疯狂了。实际上有点神奇。
I've seen a few different things. I saw that one. I forget what it was. It was the five of you kind of reminiscing and going... Do you remember that we came out a couple years ago? The Class of 92. Class of 92. Yeah.
肖恩，如果他们为你做，他们会，像肖恩一样吃邋遢乔，或者类似的东西。你知道我的意思吗？像肖恩那样擦你的嘴。但是，等等，等等，等等。但我想要进入的是，你和你的队友，你们有那个92班，史上最伟大的班级之一。
So good. I watched that when I was in the UK a couple years ago. I just loved it. And obviously known as potentially the greatest dead ball kicker of all time. I mean, you had a movie named after you, Ben, like, back in... Yeah, that's so cool. That's insane. It was kind of amazing, actually.
我记得看你们，那是什么，99年，当你们落后时，那是冠军联赛，你们赢了，你们得到了两个额外的进球。三分钟内两个进球，是的，哇。这太不可思议了。所以那个群体里紧密的家伙是谁？那是，说出他们的名字。好吧，老实说，我们都很紧密。
Do Sean, if they did it for you, they'd do, eat sloppy joes like Sean or something. You know what I mean? Wipe your mouth like Sean did. But, hang on, hang on, hang on. But what I want to get into is, you and your teammates, you guys had that Class of 92, one of the great all-time classes.
但显然一起长大的小伙子是我，加里·内维尔，菲尔·内维尔，尼基·巴特，保罗·斯科尔斯，瑞安·吉格斯。所以我们都长大了，就像那是92班，因为显然我们都在1992年出来了，内维尔兄弟，那些是内维尔兄弟，加里·内维尔，他非常直言不讳，他不断地，不断地与我的家伙杰米·卡拉格争吵，他是一个利物浦球员？加里总是在天空体育上说一些有争议的话。忍不住。是这样吗？
I remember watching you guys, what was it, 99, when you guys were down, was it Champions League and you won it, you got the two extra goals. Two goals in three minutes, yeah, wow. It was un-fucking-believable. And so who were the tight guys in that group? It was, name them. Well, we were all tight in all honesty.
我记得看你们比赛，那是什么时候，99年吧，当时你们处于劣势，是欧冠决赛吗？你们赢了，最后进了两个球。三分钟内进了两个球，哇，真是太不可思议了。那么那群人里谁关系最铁？说几个名字。老实说，我们大家关系都很铁。
But obviously the lads that grew up together was me, Gary Neville, Phil Neville, Nicky Butt, Paul Skolls, Ryan Giggs. So we all grew up, like that was the class of 92 because obviously we all came through in 1992 the Neville brothers Those are the Neville brothers Gary Neville who's very outspoken and he's constantly constantly sparring with my guy Jamie Carragher who's a who's a Liverpool player? Gary is always on Sky Sports saying something controversially. Can't help himself. Is that right?
但显然一起长大的那帮人是我、加里·内维尔、菲尔·内维尔、尼基·巴特、保罗·斯科尔斯和瑞恩·吉格斯。我们都是一起长大的，这就是所谓的“92班”，因为我们显然都是在1992年出道的。内维尔兄弟，就是加里·内维尔，他非常直言不讳，经常和我的人杰米·卡拉格争论，杰米是利物浦的球员对吧？加里总是在天空体育台发表一些有争议的言论，他就是管不住自己。是这样吗？
I love that. That is exactly right. And he's always been the same. He's always been controversial. He's always been able to talk a lot. And the funny thing, the relationship between him and Jamie Carragher, they used to hate each other as players. We all, you know, that rivalry was so intense, but they're best of friends now, which is amazing to see. I have a feeling Victoria is about to come in
我喜欢这样。这完全正确。他一直都是这样。他一直都很有争议。他一直都很能说。有趣的是，他和杰米·卡拉格之间的关系，他们做球员时曾经互相憎恨。我们都知道，那种竞争非常激烈，但他们现在是最好的朋友，这真是太神奇了。我有种预感，维多利亚快要进来了，
and stab David with her headphones. I feel like this is the weed she's talking about. I wish I was at home and I'd bring her in, trust me. She actually said to me at breakfast, she was like, we should have done it, why am I not doing it? She was like, ah! That's true, Why am I not doing it? She was like, yeah. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
她要用耳机刺大卫了。我觉得这就是她说的那个“杂草”。我真希望我在家，我会把她带进来，相信我。她早餐时确实对我说了，她说，我们本该做的，为什么我没做？她说，啊！那是真的，为什么我没做？她说，是啊。是啊，是啊，是啊。
We're gonna give her her own hour. I will just say this and then we'll leave it. I feel like I'm the David Beckham of this, of my crew of this marvelous crew. These guys are my supporting. We're the ball. And I would, except for the looks, the fashion and the athletic ability.
我们要给她一个小时的时间。我只想说这一点，然后我们就此打住。我觉得我是这个团队、这个了不起的团队里的大卫·贝克汉姆。这些人是我的后盾。我们是一个整体。除了外貌、时尚感和运动能力，我就是他们。
Barely, barely. Now, David, what part of the documentary were you most excited for the public to learn about you that perhaps they didn't know before? To be honest, I was nervous about the whole thing. When I retired eight years before, or 10 years before, it was actually 10 years, people wanted someone, they wanted me to do it then and there, there and then. And I wasn't actually ready to kind of look back. I was ready to kind of just jump into something else,
勉强，勉强。那么，大卫，纪录片中哪一部分是你最希望公众了解你，而他们之前可能不知道的？老实说，我对整件事都很紧张。当我八年前，或者十年前退役时，其实是十年前，人们当时就想让我拍，就在那时。但我其实还没准备好回顾过去。我当时准备好直接投入到别的事情中去，
which was the club in Miami. But then about two years out from my 10 year retirement, kind of anniversary, we started to discuss it and talk about it and think, okay, maybe this is the right time. So I don't know. In all honesty, one of the reasons why I wanted to do the documentary was for my family. I wanted them to have something all in one place
那就是迈阿密的俱乐部。但在我退役十周年纪念日的前两年左右，我们开始讨论这件事，并认为，好吧，也许现在是合适的时机。所以我不知道。老实说，我想拍这部纪录片的原因之一是为了我的家人。我希望他们能把所有东西都集中在一个地方，
for them to watch and for them to look back and reminisce. And that's what really we created. There was a hell of a story there from the upbringing to the different clubs that I played for, to the ups and the downs. And my career was always kind of a roller coaster, but obviously I was very lucky to be as successful as I was because of the teams that I played for
让他们观看，让他们回顾和怀念。这确实是我们所创造的。从我的成长经历到我效力过的不同俱乐部，再到起起落落，这里有一个精彩的故事。我的职业生涯一直像过山车一样，但显然我很幸运，因为我效力的球队和我的队友，我取得了如此大的成功。
and the teammates that I had. Right, and now did you have, like, was there a moment where you thought, how am I going to chase this high of all of the success that I had, and if not, what made you get out of that feeling of like, God, I can't chase this high forever, like, what am I gonna do?
对，那么你有没有过这样一个时刻，你心想，我该如何去追寻我所拥有的那种成功的高峰？如果没有，是什么让你摆脱了那种“天哪，我不可能永远追寻这种高峰，我该怎么办”的感觉？
Well, in all honesty, I'm shocked with the reaction to the documentary. I can't believe the reaction that we've had to the documentary. You should be surprised that even I watched it. In my wildest dreams, I couldn't have, you know, I wasn't expecting all of what has happened since we brought it out have, you know, I wasn't expecting all of what has happened since we bought it out. But, you know, with chasing the higher, you know, I knew that
嗯，老实说，我对纪录片的反应感到震惊。我无法相信我们对这部纪录片所得到的反应。你应该感到惊讶，连我自己都看了。在我最疯狂的梦里，我都没预料到自从我们发布它以来所发生的一切。但你知道，关于追寻高峰，我知道，
once I finished my career, I kind of planned it 10 years out, you know, before I retired. I didn't know when I was going to retire, but I always knew that I needed to step into something new. On the day that I retired, the day after, I knew that I'd have to go again, because that's just how I was brought up. My parents worked really hard, and they luckily built that into me, so I was ready to go straight after that. And nothing was gonna replace the feeling of playing soccer,
一旦我结束了职业生涯，我在退役前十年左右就计划好了。我不知道我什么时候会退役，但我一直知道我需要进入一个新的领域。在我退役的那天，第二天，我就知道我必须重新出发，因为我就是这样长大的。我的父母工作非常努力，幸运的是他们把这种精神灌输给了我，所以我退役后马上就准备好了。没有什么能取代踢球的感觉，
but I knew I needed to be busy How far after you how long after you retired was it that you purchased? Miami inter miami well, I announced I had to actually be finished playing soccer so When I signed for la I put that in my contract so I could buy a franchise at the end of my time Of playing in LA. And luckily they gave it to me. And it was for half the price of what they were worth at the time. And then obviously six years later I was able to announce it.
但我知道我需要忙碌起来。你退役后多久购买了迈阿密国际？嗯，我宣布的时候，我实际上必须结束职业生涯。当我签约洛杉矶银河队时，我在合同里写了这一条，这样我就可以在洛杉矶踢球结束时购买一支球队。幸运的是，他们给了我这个机会。而且价格只有当时球队价值的一半。然后显然六年之后我能够宣布它。
And then I was playing in Paris. My last game was in Paris. And the day after I flew to Miami and I announced the team in Miami. The day after. Wow, that's really cool. How are you liking that new role in the process, the role of ownership? You know what, it's been one of the most challenging things
当时我还在巴黎踢球。我的最后一场比赛是在巴黎。第二天我就飞往迈阿密，宣布了迈阿密球队的消息。就在第二天。哇，那真的很酷。你觉得这个新角色，也就是所有权的角色，怎么样？你知道吗，这是我做过的最具挑战性的事情之一。
that I've ever done. Whether in my career or outside of my career in the business side. Because we had to jump over a lot of like hurdles along the way. There was so many difficult moments, people turning around and saying, Miami is a really difficult sporting city.
无论是在我的职业生涯中，还是在职业生涯之外的商业领域。因为我们一路上必须跨越很多障碍。有太多困难的时刻，人们转过身来说，迈阿密是一个非常困难的体育城市。
Don't go there, don't take the team there. But I had a feeling that that was where I wanted to take the team. And it took a long time to get it up and running. And we're still jumping through different challenges, but in all honesty, my vision from day one when I presented the team and tried to put the logo together and the colors and all of that,
别去那里，别把球队带到那里。但我有一种感觉，那就是我想带球队去的地方。它花了很多时间才建立并运行起来。我们仍然在克服不同的挑战，但老实说，从第一天我展示球队、尝试设计标志、颜色以及所有这些东西时，我的愿景就是，
the last slide of the presentation that I presented to the creative guys was a picture of Messi in the Miami Jersey. So my dream was always to bring someone and him to our team. Unbelievable. I mean, how crazy that you've been,
我向创意团队展示的演示文稿的最后一张幻灯片是梅西穿着迈阿密球衣的照片。所以我的梦想一直是把某个人，也就是他，带到我们的球队。难以置信。我的意思是，你是梅西的老板，这太疯狂了。我的意思是，让我们，你知道，别掩饰了。我不能那样看。我不能，我就是不能。但这太疯狂了。而且你，不仅在迈阿密这支球队取得了成功，而且你还在一个很多球员为了那些巨大的，你知道，
you're Messi's boss. I mean, let's just, you know, let's not dress up. I can't look at it like that. I can't, I just can't. But it's pretty wild. And you, not only have you been successful with this team in Miami, but you brought over Leo Messi in a time when, and as you are well aware, a lot of players are going east to get those big, you know,
在中东寻求财富的时候，把里奥·梅西带了过来。是的。很多来自欧洲的球员，在中东寻求财富。是的。很多来自欧洲的球员，很多来自英国的球员，他们都去那里拿这些巨额薪水。著名的罗纳尔多和其他所有人。而梅西来到了迈阿密。那一定让你感到一种真正的平反，就像一种真正的信任投票，他说，
inserts of riches in the Middle East. Yeah. A lot of players from Europe, in search of riches in the Middle East. Yeah. A lot of players from Europe, a lot of players from the UK, they're all going there and getting these huge paydays. Famously, Ronaldo and everybody else. And Messi comes to Miami. And that must've felt like a real vindication for you, like a real sort of vote of confidence that he said,
你知道吗，我要去迈阿密，我要和大卫·贝克汉姆合作，我要为迈阿密效力。我的意思是，那一定感觉很好。感觉难以置信，我到现在还不敢相信。每次有人转过身对我说，你的球队里有梅西，你意识到了吗？这真的很超现实，你知道，
you know what, I'm gonna go to Miami and I'm gonna partner with David Beckham and I'm gonna play for Miami. I mean, that must have felt good. It felt unbelievable, and I still can't believe it. Every time someone turns around to me and says, you have Messi in your team, you realize that, don't you? And it really is surreal, you know,
说我们拥有可能是这项运动有史以来最伟大的球员，最成功的球员，而且他正在迈阿密踢美国职业足球大联盟（MLS）。但里奥，他的愿景一直都是，你知道，他多年前对我说，我喜欢迈阿密，有一天我想住在迈阿密，这句话一直印在我的脑海里。我想，有一天我要实现它。如果我们有机会把像他这样级别的球员带到迈阿密，那这就是我想做的。
to say that we have probably the greatest player to have ever played the game, the most successful player to ever play the game, and he's playing in Miami in the MLS. But Leo, his vision was always, you know, he turned around to me many years ago, he said, I love Miami, one day I want to live in Miami, and it stuck in my head. And I thought, I'm going to make that happen one day. If ever we ever get a chance to bring a player like him and his caliber to Miami, then that's what I want to do.
所以这花了很多时间。他在来之前四五年我们就开始了整个过程。哇。我溜进了他父亲的酒店。你知道，我说，我想签下你的儿子。我知道他现在不会来，但在某个时候，我们想把他带到迈阿密。所以我们在五年前就开始了这个过程，然后突然之间，他决定来了。是的，我真的不敢相信。
So it took a lot of time. We started the process four or five years before he came. Wow. I sneaked into his dad's hotel. You know, I said, I want to sign your son. I know he won't come now, but at some point, we want to bring him to Miami. So we started the process five years out, and then all of a sudden, he decides to come. And yeah, I actually cannot believe.
但你是对的。当时很多球员都想去沙特，而且显然他有很多报价。但他非常聪明。你知道，他非常聪明。他知道美国市场是一个多么巨大的市场，你可以拥有什么样的机会。我想他也看到了我和孩子们以及我妻子在洛杉矶的生活。你知道，那是他的决定。是的，我的意思是，然后你还得到了苏亚雷斯和乔迪·阿尔巴。我知道。这很……我知道，是的。塞尔吉奥·布斯克茨，我知道。我确实从我的马德里朋友那里得到了一些批评，因为我们现在正在建立一支巴塞罗那队。
But you're right. A lot of players were wanting to go and go into Saudi at the time, and he had a lot of offers, obviously, on the table. But he's very clever. You know, he's very clever. He knows what a massive market the US market is, the opportunities that you can have. I think he also saw the life that me,
所以，在某个时候，我们可能不得不引进一些马德里球员，但这非常令人兴奋。嗯，显然，将这些全球超级巨星带入美国足球是非常重要的。如果我没记错的话，这是你基本上开启的，从那时起，这项运动在美国确实有了很大的发展。基本上是从你开始为银河队效力时开始的。
the kids and my wife had in LA. And you know, that was his decision. Yeah, I mean, and then you also got Suarez and Jordi Alba. I know. It's quite aba. I know, yeah. Sergio Busquets, I know. I do get a little bit of stick from my Madrid mates because we're building a Barcelona team at the moment.
是的，是的，所以你开启了那里的局面，现在它达到了顶峰，目前的顶峰就是梅西。你是否看好，你是否有信心美国足球会继续增长，并有一天在知名度、上座率、授权和电视转播权等方面与我们的美式足球、棒球和篮球并驾齐驱？归根结底，很难达到棒球、美式足球、篮球那么大的规模，因为事实就是如此。
So at some point, we might have to bring some Madrid players in, but yeah, it's very exciting. Well, obviously, bringing these global superstars into American soccer is hugely important. It's something that you basically started, if I'm correct, and the sport has consequently been growing in the United States quite a lot since then. Since you started playing for the galaxy, basically.
但我认为我们在MLS和美国足球方面确实有一个真正的机会。我在2007年就很看好。我知道首先，从皇家马德里转会到洛杉矶银河队时，当时联盟里大概有13或14支球队，联盟还没有现在这么成熟。当时没有大的电视转播协议。没有大的苹果协议。所有这些东西都没有到位。所以我到了那里，它并不像我习惯的那样专业，
Yeah, yeah, and so you kinda started a thing going there and it's reached its zenith, current zenith with Messi. Are you bullish, are you confident that American soccer will continue to grow and someday be on par with our American football and baseball and basketball as far as notoriety and attendance and licensing and TV rights, all that stuff? At the end of the day, it's hard to be as big as baseball, American football, basketball, because it's just what it is.
但我知道我想要那个挑战。我知道我想要，我一直喜欢美国。我一直想住在美国。我当时的决定受到了相当严厉的批评。我当时作为一名运动员受到了批评。但我想要那个，你知道，我想要那个挑战。我能看到。你知道，我想要那个挑战，我能看到MLS的未来是什么样的。幸运的是，有很多人真正支持这个联盟。现在它已经从一个极端走向了另一个极端。
But I think we have a real opportunity with soccer in the MLS and in the US. And I was bullish back in 2007. I knew that firstly, moving from Real Madrid to the LA Galaxy, when at that time, I think there was 13 or 14 teams in the league, the league wasn't as established as it was. There wasn't a big TV deal there. There wasn't a big Apple deal. All of these things weren't in place. So I arrived and it wasn't as professional
现在，你知道，我们需要继续发展它。我们能做些什么来促进这项运动的发展呢？我真的，正如你指出的，我是利物浦的铁杆球迷。顺便说一句，大卫，当谈到足球时，我给你的唯一建议，因为你是史上最伟大的球员之一，我会说的是，你有一位很好的教练在迈阿密国际，但你知道我要说什么，
as I'm used to. But I knew that I wanted that challenge. I knew that I wanted, I always loved the US. I always wanted to live in US. And my decision at that time was criticized, like quite heavily. And I was criticized as an athlete at that time. But I wanted that, you know, I wanted that challenge. And I could see. You know, I wanted that challenge and I could see, you know, what the future looked like in the MLS. And luckily, there's been a lot of people that have really put a lot behind, you know, this league. And now it's gone from one extreme to the other.
谁需要进来，因为他快要空闲了。他是我的心头好。我知道，你知道吗？如果我要说谁需要进来，因为他快要空闲了。我知道他是我的心头好。我知道你会知道，如果我能把你的枪手带过来，让我成为那三个人之一……你别又开始了？你会挨骂的。我必须承认，即使作为曼联球迷，我也喜欢他。我喜欢他的性格，我喜欢他的个性，你知道，我喜欢他为这项运动带来的东西。而且，你知道，听到他说他要离开利物浦，显然作为曼联球迷，
And now, you know, we need to continue to grow it. And what can we do to sort of grow the sport? I really, you know, as you pointed out, I'm a massive Liverpool fan. By the way, my only piece of advice I'll ever give you, David, when it comes to football, because you're one of the all-time greats, I will say this, is, and you've got a good coach manager over at Inter Miami, but you know what I'm gonna say
我会遭到一些曼联朋友的痛骂。但我很难过看到他离开。我很难过。你知道，他为俱乐部所做的，他为这项运动所做的，是不可思议的。把他拉到迈阿密你的怀里？大卫，你应该知道，还有这么多钱……我们会把它凑齐的，我们会把它凑齐的。我想帮忙实现这一点。你应该知道，几周前我在加拿大参加冰球全明星赛，他们让我……那是真的吗？
who needs to come in, because he's about to be available. He's my guy. I know, and you know what? If gonna say who needs to come in because he's about to be available. I know he's my guy I know you're gonna know what if I can bring your gun over and let me be the three Don't you start your again? You're gonna get it. You're gonna get an earful I must admit even as a men's United fan. I love you again. I I love I love his character I love his personality you know, I love what he brings to the sport. And, you know, to hear him say that he's leaving Liverpool, and obviously being a Manchester United fan,
嘿，他们让我成为某种……那是真的吗，呃？他们让我成为某种名人队长之类的。所以我当时和康纳·麦克戴维在一起，他是史上最伟大的球员之一，我发表了演讲，说，你为更衣室里的孩子们准备了演讲吗？我说，我当然有。我所做的是我收集了一堆尤尔根·克洛普的名言，
I'm going to get killed by some of my Manchester United friends. But I'm sad to see him leave. I'm sad. You know, what he's done for the club and what he's done for the sport, has been incredible. Pull him close to your breast in Miami? David you should know this much money left We're gonna put it together we're gonna put it together I want to help make this happen you should know a couple weeks ago I was in Canada for the for the any the hockey all-star game and they had me be like is that right?
我把它变成了一篇演讲。我开始了，因为他所有的演讲都那么鼓舞人心，对吧？他与人交谈的方式超越了体育。然后我以“当我第一次来到多特蒙德时”结束，然后所有的球员都看着我，好像在说，多特蒙德，他在说什么，总之。我们要把你拉进俱乐部。
Hey, they had me be a sort... Is that right, eh? They had me be sort of like a celebrity captain, whatever. And so I was with Connor McDavid, who's one of the greats of all time, and I gave a speech, said, you have a speech for the boys in the locker room. I said, I sure do. And what I had done was I pulled together a bunch of Jurgen Klopp quotes,
但我想要问的问题是，我们能做些什么来让足球，某种程度上，我们如何在这个国家改进它，你知道，无论是青年学院还是仅仅发展这项运动？因为我真的希望年轻人去踢球。是的，嗯，老实说，当我2007年刚来的时候，我和专员坐在一起，我说，好吧，跟我谈谈MLS的学院，
and I made it into a speech. And I started, and because all his speeches are so inspiring, right? And it kind of goes beyond sport, the way he talks to people. And then I ended it by saying, when I first came to Dortmund, and then all the players looked at me like, Dortmund, what is he talking, anyway. We're going to get you in the club.
他说，我们没有任何学院。我说，好吧，那么，每支球队都必须有一个学院。我很自豪地说，每支球队现在都有从12岁到23岁的学院系统。我们在迈阿密，这对我是最令人兴奋的事情之一，学院，因为去年我们有六个年轻孩子进入了一线队。这些是你需要做的事情。你知道，而且，你需要这样做，
But I want to get my question was, what can we do to make football, sort of, how can we improve it in this country, you know, whether it's youth academies or just grow the sport? Because I really want young people to play. Yeah, well, in all honesty, when I came in 2007, I sat with the commissioner, I said, okay, talk to me about the academies
但你也需要引进明星。你知道，把里奥带到联盟不仅仅是关于，你知道，给美国和MLS一份礼物，显然是给美国和MLS，显然是给迈阿密球迷，更多的是关于他能为我们的学院球员做什么。并继续你开始的事情。加雷斯·贝尔也做了，伟大的加雷斯·贝尔。
that run through the MLS. He said, we don't have any. I said, OK, well then, every team has to have an academy. And I'm proud to say that every team now has academy systems that run from 12 years old up until 23. And we in Miami, that's one of the most exciting things for me, the academy, because we had six young kids in our first team last year. And those are the things that you need to do. You know, and also, you need to do that,
是的，我们爱加雷斯。我们爱他。顺便说一句，他是个很棒的高尔夫球手。他是个很棒的高尔夫球手。他是个很棒的高尔夫球手。天哪。大卫，你的高尔夫球水平怎么样？还可以，还可以。我敢打赌你的高尔夫球水平，大卫？还可以。
but you also need to bring stars. You know, bringing Leo to the league wasn't just about, you know, giving a gift to the US and the MLS and obviously to the US and the MLS and obviously to the Miami fans, it was more about what he can do for our Academy players. And continuing what you started. Gareth Bale did it too, the great Gareth Bale.
还可以。我敢打赌它相当不错。还可以。下次你在洛杉矶时来和我们一起玩。好的。我没那么好。你的……
Yep, we love Gareth. We love him. He's a great golfer by the way. He's a great golfer. He's a great golfer. Good Lord. How's your golf game, David? It's okay, it's okay. I bet your golf game, David? It's okay.
加雷斯让我们尴尬了。加雷斯，他简直让我们尴尬了。是吗，JB？是的。而且不仅仅是发型。不。我们马上回来。感谢我们的一位新赞助商Liquid Death支持本节目。马上回来。一系列清脆的低糖苏打水、低糖冰茶和清爽的山泉水。
It's okay. I'll bet it's pretty damn good. It's okay. Come play with us. Come play with us next time you're in LA. Okay. I'm not that good. What's your...
但为什么要叫Liquid Death（液体死亡）？他们在这里是为了通过他们的可回收罐来粉碎一次性塑料瓶的使用。那不是很棒吗？我其实很喜欢这些口味。我喜欢Severed Lime（断头青柠）。我喜欢Mango Chainsaw（芒果电锯）和Cherry Obituary（樱桃讣告）。首先，我喜欢这些名字。但这三种都太美味了。
Gareth embarrassed us. Gareth, he literally embarrassed us. Did he, JB? Yeah. And it wasn't just the hair. No. We'll be right back. Thank you to one of our new sponsors, Liquid Death, for supporting the show. Be right back. of crisp low sugar sodas, low sugar iced teas, and refreshing mountain spring water.
它们很棒。你打开它们，它们就直接下肚了。太清爽了。你可以通过亚马逊Prime获得Liquid Death山泉水风味气泡水和冰茶八连包的免费送货，或者在当地的7-Eleven、塔吉特、沃尔玛、全食超市或Instacart上买一罐或一箱。前往liquiddeath.com/smartless查看他们所有健康、可无限回收的饮料，并找到离你最近的零售商。那是liquiddeath.com/smartless。Liquiddeath.com/smartless。
But why the name Liquid Death? They're here to crush the use of single use plastic bottles with their recyclable cans. Isn't that awesome? I actually love the flavors. I love severed lime. I love mango chainsaw and cherry obituary. I love the names first of all. But all those three are so delicious.
我们得到了State Farm的支持。购买新房或新车时有很多话要说，但只有一句话可以帮助你保护它们。像个好邻居，State Farm就在那里。有了State Farm代理人，你知道有人在那里通过帮助你选择你需要的保险来帮助保护你的未来。有这么多保险选项，
They're yummy. You crack them open, they go right down. It's so refreshing. You can get free shipping of Liquid Death's Mountain Water flavored sparkling and iced tea, eight packs with Amazon Prime, or grab a can or a case at your local 7-Eleven, Target, Walmart, Whole Foods, or on Instacart. Go to liquiddeath.com slash smartless to check out all their healthy, infinitely recyclable beverages and find your closest retailer. That's liquiddeath.com slash smartless. Liquiddeath.com slash smartless.
知道你能找到适合你的东西感觉很好。当事情变得复杂，你需要寻求帮助的方法时，State Farm也为你提供了选择。也许你喜欢亲自处理事情，或者通过电话与当地代理人联系，或者你更喜欢在statefarm.com或他们的获奖应用程序上操作。State Farm让你以自己的方式做事。或者你更喜欢在statefarm.com或他们的获奖应用程序上操作。State Farm让你以自己的方式做事。所以当你需要帮助保护
We get support from State Farm. There is a lot to say when buying a new home or car, but only one thing to say that can help you protect them. Like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. With a State Farm agent, you know someone is there to help protect your future by helping you choose the coverage you need. With so many coverage options,
最重要的事情时，记得说，像个好邻居，State Farm就在那里。SmartList得到了FedEx的支持。FedEx提供送货照片证明、无包裹和无纸化退货，以及周六向美国98%地区和周日向50%地区提供周末送货服务。这才是安心。对我来说，除非我知道事情都安排好了，事情有条不紊，否则我晚上睡不着觉，
it feels good knowing you can find what fits for you. When things get complicated and you need ways to get help, State Farm gives you options there too. Maybe you like to handle things in person or on the phone with your local agent, or you prefer to do it on statefarm.com or on their award-winning app. State Farm lets you do things your way agent. Or you prefer to do it on statefarm.com or on their award-winning app. State Farm lets you do things your way. So when you need help protecting the
这就是我喜欢FedEx的原因，也是我喜欢有送货照片证明的原因。你们不都喜欢吗？知道他们被覆盖了，因为他们拍了照片，而且就在你的前台阶上，所以你知道你被覆盖了，他们也被覆盖了。FedEx的每个人都被覆盖了。这感觉真好。
things that matter most, remember to say, like a good neighbor, State Farm is there. SmartList is supported by FedEx. FedEx offers picture-proof of delivery, package-less and paper-less returns, as well as weekend home delivery to 98% of the US on Saturday and 50% on Sunday. Now that's peace of mind. For me, I can't sleep at night unless I know things are in place, there's an order to things,
太安全了。我喜欢它。查看FedEx服务指南以获取送货信息。FedEx地面服务也比UPS地面服务更快地到达更多地点。看看FedEx能为你的业务做些什么。绝对，肯定，FedEx。我是British Scandal的爱丽丝和马特。马特，如果我们有一张宾果卡，上面会有什么？哦，引人入胜的故事讲述、自负的白人男性和可疑的幽默。
and that's why I love FedEx, and that's why I love having picture-proof delivery. Don't you all love that? Knowing that they're covered because they took the picture and it's on your front step, so you know that you're covered and that they're covered. Everybody's covered at FedEx. It's such a good feeling.
如果这听起来像你的那杯茶，你会喜欢我们的播客，British Scandal，这个节目每周我们都会为你带来来自这片绿色且并不总是那么……如果这听起来像你的那杯茶，你会喜欢我们的播客，British Scandal，这个节目每周我们都会为你带来来自这片绿色且并不总是那么宜人的土地的故事。我们研究过间谍、政客、媒体大亨、国王，没有人是安全的。而且了解我们的国家，我们很快就不会失业。在任何你收听播客的地方关注British Scandal。现在回到节目。除了足球，你喜欢玩或观看的最喜欢的运动是什么？我喜欢篮球。
It's so secure. I love it. See the FedEx Service Guide for delivery information. FedEx ground service is also faster to more locations than UPS ground. See what FedEx can do for your business. Absolutely, positively FedEx. Alice and Matt here from British Scandal. Matt, if we had a bingo card, what would be on there? Oh, compelling storytelling, egotistical white men and dubious humour.
你喜欢吗？篮球？我喜欢它。你是迈阿密热火队的球迷吗？不，我是湖人队的球迷。我一直是湖人队的球迷。我一直是湖人队的球迷。然后显然当我搬到洛杉矶时，我能够每周去看比赛，我确保我每周都去看比赛。
If that sounds like your cup of tea, you will love our podcast, British Scandal, the show where every week we bring you stories from this green and not always a Schumer. If that sounds like your cup of tea, you will love our podcast, British Scandal, the show where every week we bring you stories from this green and not always so pleasant land. We've looked at spies, politicians, media magnates, a king, no one is safe. And knowing our country, we won't be out of a job anytime soon. Follow British Scandal wherever you listen to your podcasts. And now back to the show. What is your favorite sport aside from soccer that you enjoy playing and or watching? I love basketball.
我发现有一点很奇怪，我总是这么说，即使在早期的比赛和赛季中期的比赛中，离结束还有两分钟，人们就离开座位回家了。没人想在洛杉矶陷入交通堵塞。嗯，杰森需要回家。是的，我得回家。我得去……
Do you? Basketball? I love it. Are you a Miami Heat fan? No, I'm a Lakers fan. I've always been a Lakers fan. I've always been a Lakers fan. And then obviously when I moved to LA, I was able to go to the games every week and I made sure that I go to the game every week.
我总是待到最后，首先因为我是个忠实的球迷。你也是从斯台普斯中心（当时叫斯台普斯中心）下面的隧道里开SUV离开的。你不必处理从大停车场出来的交通混乱。那是真的。别让他尴尬。
And what I found a little bit strange and I always say it that even through the early games and the middle of the season games, two minutes to go, people are leaving the seats and going home. No one wants to get caught in traffic in LA. Well, Jason needs to get home. Yeah, I gotta get home. I gotta get on the slip piece.
你应得的。你赢得了那个。但科比在球场上。所以我不可能不看科比在球场上的每一秒。是的，我明白了。所以这更多是关于那个，而不是其他任何事情。我是湖人队的球迷。是的，是的，这说得通。我也是湖人队的球迷。
I always stayed right to the end, firstly because I'm a loyal fan. You're also leaving in the SUV from the tunnel under the Staples Center, what was then called the Staples Center. You don't have to deal with the nonsense of traffic getting out of the big lot. That is true. Don't embarrass him.
大卫，我们，每隔一段时间，我们就会有一个幸运的听众打进来提问。哦，不。我不知道你是否在你的板子上看到了。哦，这是给威尔的。这位听众来自纽约市，名叫贾斯汀·T·法瑞尔。他长得太帅了。
And you've deserved that. You've earned that. But Kobe was on the court. So there was no way I was not going to watch every second of Kobe being on the court. Yeah, I get it. So it's more about that than anything else. I'm a Lakers fan. Yeah, yeah, that makes sense. I'm a Lakers fan too.
他说这里……别说那个，别说那个。不过他的手臂很冷。所以威尔，他说，他说，我喜欢这个节目，威尔。你一直是一个巨大的利物浦支持者。如你所知，你的嘉宾贝克汉姆先生有时并没有受到利物浦球迷最热情的接待，但因为他是一个很棒的人，是一个顶级的好人，
David, we have, every once in a while, we get a lucky caller will break through with a question. Oh no. I don't know if you're seeing it there on your board. Oh, this is for Will. This caller is from New York City named Justin T. Fucking Pharrell. He is so good looking.
他慷慨地原谅了他们。我的问题是，作为一名利物浦球迷，你是否想利用这个时刻，在记录上，代表所有利物浦人，向贝克汉姆先生美丽的脸道歉，并承认你错了，你应该闭上你的大嘴巴。这是一个问题。
He says here... Don't say that, don't say that. His arms are cold though. So Will, he says, he says, I love the show, Will. You've always been a huge Liverpool supporter. As you know, your guest Mr. Beckham has at times not had the warmest of receptions by Liverpool fans, but because he is a wonderful man and a top bloke,
首先，当他说闭上你的大嘴巴时，这与其说是一个问题，不如说是一个观点。那里有很多观点。是的。有很多。我会。你能道歉吗？
he has generously forgiven them. My question is, as a Liverpool fan, would you like to use this moment on the record and on behalf of all Liverpoolians to apologize to Mr. Beckham's beautiful face and admit that you were wrong and you should shut your big fat mouth. That's a question.
我会为所有的红军球迷道歉。因为。哇，你以后没法回安菲尔德了。我知道，这是真的。我五月份要回安菲尔德。因为我想在尤尔根结束之前见见他。但不，我会为粗鲁的行为道歉。我肯定会。看起来他这里有一个后续问题。他还有一个给威尔的后续问题。
First of all, less of a question and more of an opinion when he says shut your big fat mouth. There's a lot of opinion there. Yeah. There's a lot of. I would. Can you apologize?
晚上，你在胸部使用润肤霜还是普通的处方烧伤膏？他说他可以在节目外得到答案。他现在挂断了。他真是不可思议。是的。大卫，我有一个问题要……我知道。
I will apologize for all the Reds fans out there. Because. Wow, you're not gonna be able to go back to Anfield. I know, it's true. I'm going back to Anfield in May. Because I want to see Jurgen before he wraps it up. But no, I will apologize for rude behavior. For sure I will. Looks like he's got a follow-up question here. He's got a follow-up question also for Will.
我们都有。他有很棒的手臂。手臂是什么……为什么他总是把手臂举起来？是的，我们都有。手臂，为什么他总是把手臂举起来？是的。嗯，为什么要隐藏它们呢？我的意思是，如果你有那些手臂，我从来没有……有人身材这么好，对于一个这么不爱运动的人来说。你向他扔球，他往反方向跑。你向他扔球，他往反方向跑。天哪。现在大卫，你提到了，你知道，
At night, do you use moisturizer on your chest or just regular prescription burn cream? And he says he can just take the answer off air. He's hanging up now. He's unbelievable. Yeah. David, I have a question for... I know.
我关于纪录片的问题，关于你遇到的所有那些戏剧性事件。坐在这里和你交谈，以前从未见过你，你看起来像那种人，我猜，你给我的印象是一个能够识别可能潜在的戏剧性或争议的人或情况的人，
We all do. He's got great arms. What is the arms... Why has he always got his arms up? Yeah We all do The arms why is he go always got his arms up? Yeah. Well, why would you why would you hide them? I mean if you've got those arms, I've never Somebody's in such good shape for somebody who's so unathletic You throw a ball at him he runs the other direction You throw a ball at him, he runs the other direction. Oh my God. Now David, you mentioned like, you know,
就像你提到的你的朋友，因为所有的争议总是让自己陷入麻烦。你现在逃避那个吗，在你一生中经历了这么多戏剧性事件之后，与记者、新闻业，你所处或继续从事的领域？新闻业，我不撒谎。新闻业。去他的，我为此倒下了。
my question about the documentary, about all that drama that you encountered. Just sitting here talking to you, never having met you before, you seem like the kind of guy, and I'm guessing, you strike me as someone who, that recognizes people or situations that could potentially be drama or controversy,
你现在老了，能认出来了吗？我想他明白了。谢谢你，肖恩。不，我不逃避它。我不逃避它。真的吗？不。真的吗？
like you mentioned your mate that always gets himself into trouble because of all the controversy. Do you run from that now, having been through so much drama your whole life, with reporters, journalism, the field that you were in or continue to be in? Journalisms, I'm not gonna lie. Journalism. Fuck it, I'm falling back for that.
不，我真的不。这只是，你知道，它在我的生活中已经存在很长时间了，而且，你知道，一切发生都是有原因的。我必须经历那段困难时期，才能拥有我所拥有的职业生涯。我只是说，因为你太随和、冷静、轻松了。请告诉我妻子这一点。请告诉我妻子这一点。这也很好地锻炼了你成为一个伟大的丈夫，
Do you recognize it now that you're older? I think he's got it. Thank you, Sean. No, I don't run for it. I don't run for it. You really? No. Really?
虽然她不需要任何帮助来驾驭媒体，但作为一个好父亲，可以帮助解释一些具有挑战性的事情。对于球队来说，当其中一些球员开始经历同样的媒体审查等事情时，也是一个伟大的老板。所以你拥有一个你赢得的职位，这将要求你必须创造、管理的所有事情，这真是太棒了，你知道吗？嗯，让我说这一点，大卫，让我问你这个，因为如果我们能回溯一下，这可能会有助于了解这一点。你，显然你做了很多，我们谈论了很多这些事情，你现在对生活中的现状感到满意吗？我太高兴了。
No, I really don't. It's just, you know, it's been part of my life for a long time and, you know, everything happens for a long time and everything happens for a reason. I had to go through that difficult time to maybe have the career that I had. I'm just saying, cause you're so mellow and cool and easy. Please tell my wife that. Please tell my wife that. It's also conditioned you well to be a great husband,
别哭，回答这个问题。等等。对不起。我在生活中吗？我太高兴了。别哭，回答这个问题。等等。我非常高兴。我非常高兴，因为我觉得自己很幸运，拥有了我所拥有的职业生涯，为我效力过的球队效力，并体验了这一切。
although she doesn't need any help navigating media, but a good father to help explain what some challenging stuff can be. Also a great owner for the team when some of these players start going through some of the same media scrutiny and stuff. So it's so great that you have a position that you've earned that is going to demand all of the things
我一直想要的一件事，我很幸运，我在遇到维多利亚时就遇到了她，因为我一直想早点生孩子，因为我一直想早点生孩子。我一直想让孩子们经历我的职业生涯。我很幸运，三个男孩都经历了我效力过的大部分球队。这真的很酷。
you've had to create, manage, you know? Well, let me say this, David, let me ask you this, because this might help inform that if we can sort of backtrack. Are you, obviously you've done a lot, we've talked about a lot of these things, are you happy right now with where you are in life? I'm so happy.
对我来说，这是我生活中非常重要的一部分。是的，那是纪录片中最酷的部分之一，当时你看着屏幕上的她，你说，我要娶那个女孩。我的意思是，这太疯狂了。然后你遇到了她，然后你娶了她。我的意思是，这太疯狂了。而且你们仍然结婚。
Without crying, answer the question. Hang on. I'm sorry. I are in life? I'm so happy. Without crying, answer the question. Hang on. I am very happy. I'm very happy because I feel very blessed to have had the career that I've had and played for the teams that I have and experienced that.
而且你们仍然结婚，是的。七月就25年了。那太棒了。嗯，那确实太棒了。我想我问这个的原因是因为如果你快乐，而且你看起来确实很快乐，你有很棒的孩子，而且你和他们很亲近，这是显而易见的，这真的表现出来了。你和你的妻子真的很亲近。
And the one thing that I always wanted for me, I was lucky I met Victoria when I met her because I always wanted to have kids young because I always wanted to have kids young. I always wanted to have kids that lived through my career with me. And I was lucky the three boys all lived through most of the teams that I played for. That's really cool.
但每个人在生活中都会经历一些事情，对吧？就像你总是会经历狗屎一样。我其实，你知道我总是引用什么吗，我不知道你是否看了那个《孤注一掷》（All or Nothing），托特纳姆热刺的赛季，穆里尼奥在那里面待了一部分，对吧？是的。那太棒了。我建议人们去看它。它真的很好。
And that for me was a really important part of my life. Yes, and that was one of the coolest parts of the documentary when you were like, you looked at her on screen and you're like, I'm gonna marry that girl. I mean, that's crazy. And then you met her and then you married her. I mean, that's just nuts. And you're still married.
但我喜欢他所说的一件事，就是他，我记得在中场休息时，他正在和球员们交谈，他说，看，对方球队会得分。他们会拥有控球权。问题是，你如何应对？如果你能应对，你知道，这在生活中也是如此。
And you're still married, yeah. 20, 25 years in July. That's awesome. Well, that is awesome. And I guess the reason I ask that is because if you're happy and you seem like you are and you've got great kids and you're really close to them, that's evident, that really comes through. And you and your wife are really close.
我一直都在想这件事。会有一些时候你不会有最好的一天，会有别人得到你想要的东西，等等等等。但你如何应对它？如果最后你变得快乐，那么这就是你的旅程。是的。这是我认为我和维多利亚在看完纪录片后，在一切结束后，我们最终看了它，可能都会感到情绪激动的事情之一，
But everybody goes through stuff in life, right? Like it's like you're always going to go through shit. I actually, you know what I quote all the time is, I don't know if you watch that All or Nothing, the Tottenham season, and Mourinho was on there for part of that, right? Yeah. It was great. I advise people to watch it. It's really good.
那是我们看着对方时说的一件事，就像，我不知道我们是如何度过过去27年的，但我们做到了。我们有一个了不起的家庭，我们有很棒的企业，我们很幸福。是的，当然，当你和某人在一起那么长时间时，当然会有起起落落。每个人都知道这一点，归根结底，我们很幸运，因为我们在那些时刻拥有彼此，你知道，她是辣妹，我为曼联效力，即使在我们经历困难时期时，我们实际上确实拥有彼此来互相支持，那才是最好的部分。
But I love one of the things that he said and is that he, I remember at halftime, he's talking to the players and he said, look, the other team is gonna score. They're gonna have possession. The question is, how do you cope? And if you can cope with that, you know, and it's true with life.
我们显然，我们见面时是21岁和22岁。我们结婚时是23岁和24岁。我们在23岁时有了第一个儿子。所以当我们有了第一个儿子布鲁克林时，那也确实为家庭增加了另一层意义，我们当时的责任就是对我们的儿子。那些，你知道。现在，让我问你这个。
I think about it all the time. There are going to be times where you're not going to have your best day, where somebody else is going to get the thing you want, blah, blah, blah, blah. But how do you cope with it? And if at the end you end up being happy, then that was your journey. Yeah. And that's one of the things I think we both, me and Victoria, probably both get emotional about and after watching the documentary, after everything was over and we watched it finally,
你说企业和家庭，这真的很酷。你是如何打造商业头脑的？因为很多体育人物没有那种被锻炼的大脑侧面，或者他们想锻炼大脑的那一部分吗？但你似乎被它吸引了。你是怎么做到的？
that's the one thing that we looked at each other and was like, I don't know how we got through, you know, the last 27 years, but we did. And we have an amazing family, we have amazing businesses, and we're happy. And yeah, of course course when you're with someone for that amount of time Of course you have your ups and downs. Everybody knows that and at the end of the day We were lucky because we had each other at those moments, you know, she was a Spice girl I was playing for Manchester United and even when we were going through the difficult times we actually we actually had each other to feed off and And that was that was the that. And that was the best part.
我想在我的整个职业生涯中，我很幸运能进入不同的领域，无论是成为某些品牌的代言人等等。多年来，我能够与伟大的人一起工作。我和阿迪达斯合作已经快30年了。所以我拥有的很多品牌和合作伙伴都是长期合作伙伴。
We obviously, we were 21 and 22 when we met. We got married when we was 23 and 24. And we had our first son when he was 23. So as soon as we had our first son, Brooklyn, that really also added another layer to obviously the family and our responsibilities then were to our son. And those, you know. Now, let me ask you this.
所以商业是我一直感兴趣的事情。即使从很小的时候起，我就知道我停止踢球的那一刻，我想在商业世界中拥有另一种生活。老实说，把迈阿密的部分放进去，是我想要留下的遗产的重要组成部分，你知道，在比赛中。你知道，我想成为一支球队的老板。我想在美国。
You said businesses as well as family, which is really cool. How did you craft a business mind? Because a lot of sports figures don't have that side of their brain that gets exercised like that, or do they want to exercise that part of their brain? But you seem to gravitate towards it. What was, how did you do that?
嗯，所以如果我有机会这样做，那就是我想要的。但在商业方面，你知道，有很多事情在我的业务中持续进行，我是商业方面，你知道，有很多事情在我的业务中持续进行。我很幸运拥有我所拥有的业务，但这确实是我一直想做的事情。这真的很令人印象深刻。肖恩，你说你的很多合作伙伴都是阿迪达斯。
I think throughout my career, I was lucky to go into different things, wherever it was being the face of certain brands and things like that. And I was able to work with great people over the years. I've been with Adidas for almost 30 years now. So a lot of the people and brands that I have and partners that I have are long-term partners.
很难看清，因为天黑了，但是……是的，是的，是的。大卫，你现在旅行更多了吗？你现在比作为球员时更忙吗？我比作为球员时忙得多……因为老实说……你现在应该轻松一点。我知道。
So the business was something I was always interested in. Even from a young age, I knew that the moment I stopped playing, I wanted to have another life after that in the business world. And in all honesty, putting the Miami part was in, was a big part of the legacy that I wanted to leave, you know, in the game. You know, I wanted to be an owner of a team. I wanted to be in the U S.
你就像我看到的一切，你就像在不同的城市，比如开一家店。我知道，但我享受那一部分。我喜欢旅行，我喜欢工作，老实说，这是我业务的重要组成部分。所以我生活中的那一部分，我很享受。是的。大卫，我母亲是英国人，所以我喜欢英国人，
Um, so if I got the opportunity to do that, that was what I wanted. But on the business side, you know, there's a lot of things that, that have continued throughout my business and I'm, I'm the business side, you know, there's a lot of things that have continued throughout my business. And I'm lucky to have, you know, the business that I have, but it's something that I always wanted to do. It's really impressive. Sean, you were saying that a lot of your partners were Adidas.
我很想知道关于你最典型的英国特质是什么？我喜欢烤肉。我喜欢烤肉晚餐。哦，那可能是关于我最典型的部分。现在我们说的是牛肉烤肉，对吧？鸡肉烤肉。鸡肉烤肉。我选鸡肉烤肉。是的，我明白了。我明白了。杰森，当你过来吃晚饭时，我们吃了鸡肉烤肉。是的，我们吃了。是的，那是你让她给我们做的吗？你喜欢在英格兰，比如在周日，吃一顿正宗的烤肉晚餐。这是我最喜欢做的事情。这是我最喜欢做的事情。
It was hard to see because it was dark, but... Yeah, yeah, yeah. David, are you traveling more now? Are you busier now than you ever were as a player? I'm so much more busy... busier than I was when I was a player because in all honesty... You're supposed to take it easy now. I know.
你喜欢去酒吧吃午餐吗？你喜欢在周日吗？我确实喜欢酒吧午餐。我喜欢酒吧午餐。我的孩子们也喜欢。什么乐队？因为我喜欢英国乐队。我是听着，威尔也是，听着英国流行音乐长大的。
You're like everything I see, you're like in a different city, like opening a thing. I know, but I enjoy that part of it. I enjoy to travel, I enjoy to work, and in all honesty, that's a big part of my business. So that part of my life, I enjoy it. Yeah. David, my mother's British, so I love people who are British,
你就像我所见的一切，你就像在另一个城市，就像开启了一件事。我知道，但我享受其中的那部分。我喜欢旅行，我喜欢工作，老实说，这是我生意中很大的一部分。所以我生活的这一部分，我很享受。是的。大卫，我母亲是英国人，所以我很喜欢英国人，
and I'd love to know what is the most quintessentially British thing about you? I love a roast. I love a roast dinner. Oh, that is probably the most quintessential part about me. Now that is a beef roast we're talking about, yes? Chicken roast. Chicken roast. I go for chicken roast. Yeah, I get it. I got it. Jason, when you came over for dinner, we had chicken roast. Yeah, we did. Yes, is that what you asked her to cook us? You like being in England, like on a Sunday, and having a proper roast dinner. It's my favorite thing to do. It's my favorite thing to do.
我很想知道你身上最典型的英国特质是什么？我喜欢烤肉。我喜欢烤肉晚餐。哦，那可能是我身上最典型的特质了。我们说的是牛肉烤肉，对吧？鸡肉烤肉。鸡肉烤肉。我选鸡肉烤肉。是的，我明白了。我懂了。杰森，你来吃晚饭的时候，我们吃的就是鸡肉烤肉。是的，我们吃了。没错，那是你让她给我们做的吗？你喜欢待在英国，比如在周日，吃一顿地道的烤肉晚餐。这是我最喜欢做的事。这是我最喜欢做的事。
Do you like going for a pub lunch? Do you like on a Sunday? I do like a pub lunch. I like a pub lunch. And my kids love it. What bands? Because I love British band. I grew up on, Will did too, like on British pop
你喜欢去酒吧吃午餐吗？你喜欢在周日去吗？我确实喜欢酒吧午餐。我喜欢酒吧午餐。我的孩子们也喜欢。什么乐队？因为我喜欢英国乐队。我是听着英国流行音乐长大的，威尔也是。
and stuff like that. Who do you listen to? Stone Roses. Love the Stone Roses, love the Stone Roses. I'm a big Stone Roses fan because obviously growing up in Manchester, in the 90s, it was all about Stone Roses, Oasis. Well Oasis is Man City though, sadly.
之类的。你听谁的歌？石玫瑰乐队（Stone Roses）。我超爱石玫瑰，超爱。我是石玫瑰的铁粉，因为显然在曼彻斯特长大，90年代的时候，到处都是石玫瑰和绿洲乐队（Oasis）。不过遗憾的是，绿洲乐队是曼城队的球迷。
What is the best British slang word or phrase? And can you give us an example of how you'd use it? Oh, well, I was actually, my daughter started trying to ask me some slang the other day. She was like, dad, you always talk about these like slang words as a cockney. And I was like, okay, I'm trying to,
最好的英国俚语词汇或短语是什么？你能给我们举个例子说明怎么用吗？哦，其实我女儿前几天开始试着问我一些俚语。她说，爸爸，你总是像个伦敦东区人一样说这些俚语。我就说，好吧，我正在试着，
because I don't really want her to start talking slang in all honesty. So I was like, okay. So Harpy, you've just run up the apple and pears. And she was like, what do you mean? She was like, well, that's what it is. It's status. You know, you've just run up the apple and pears. So I've been trying...
因为老实说，我不太想让她开始说俚语。所以我说，好吧。比如，Harpy，你刚跑上楼梯（apples and pears）。她就问，你什么意思？我说，嗯，就是这个意思。这是押韵俚语。你知道，你刚跑上楼梯。所以我一直在试着……
Apple and pears? Yeah. Apple and pears. Yeah. Those kind of cockney, you know, slang she started to ask about. But, you know, Victoria would kill, but Victoria would kill me. She would kill me, but if I was trying to teach her those kind of words and things, she would be happy.
楼梯（Apple and pears）？对。楼梯。对。她开始问那些伦敦东区的俚语。但是，你知道，维多利亚会杀了我的，如果我教她那些词，她会杀了我的，她会很开心的。
You're obviously still staying in incredible shape. What about some of that British food there? What's your favorite piece of crap over there in England? Would it be something like that? I'm from the East End of London, so I grew up on it's pie and mash. So it's simple. It's a mint pie. It's your most simple mash.
你显然一直保持着令人难以置信的身材。那英国食物怎么样？你在英国最喜欢的垃圾食品是什么？是那种东西吗？我来自伦敦东区，所以我从小吃派和土豆泥（pie and mash）。很简单。就是肉馅派。最简单的土豆泥。
No butter, just salt. And then it's like a gravy called liquor. And it's stewed eels and parsley. I'll do that. I'll do that.'s stewed eels and parsley. And then jelly eels. So jelly eels is eels. So you cut up eels and then- Eel like the fish, the snake?
不加黄油，只加盐。然后是一种叫“利口酒”（liquor）的肉汁。还有炖鳗鱼和欧芹。我会吃那个。我会吃那个。炖鳗鱼和欧芹。还有果冻鳗鱼。果冻鳗鱼就是鳗鱼。把鳗鱼切开然后——像鱼一样的鳗鱼，像蛇一样？
The fish, the sea snake? Yep, yep, in gelatin. In gelatin. Oh, good Lord. It's not for everyone, it's not for everyone, but that's- Not for anyone. David, you've been a very, very nice man to join us and a great man during this interview.
鱼，海蛇？对，对，在明胶里。在明胶里。哦，天哪。这不适合所有人，不适合所有人，但那是——不适合任何人。大卫，你真是个非常好的人，能加入我们，在这次采访中表现得太棒了。
I love you. You're the best. What a thrill. What an absolute thrill, man. It's a thrill for me to be on here. I'm a big fan of all you guys and obviously what you do. And to be on here is a huge privilege So thank you set the bar very high for Victoria to try to jump over
我爱你。你是最棒的。太激动了。绝对令人激动，伙计。能在这里做客对我来说也是一种激动。我是你们所有人的大粉丝，显然也喜欢你们做的事情。能在这里是巨大的荣幸，所以谢谢你们，为维多利亚设定的门槛太高了，让她去尝试超越。
She'll kill it in a second. Don't worry. We can't wait to have it He said to me you can bring the looks and I'm bringing the humor. That's Her words not mine, let's let's all let's all have bangers and all that stuff without the eel when you're here. Well, you're invited to come to Miami or when you come to London and we'll go to a pie mash. I would love that, I would love that. Fantastic.
她一秒钟就能搞定。别担心。我们迫不及待想让她来了。他说，你可以负责颜值，我负责幽默。那是她的话，不是我的。让我们都来点香肠之类的，不加鳗鱼。好吧，欢迎你们来迈阿密，或者你们来伦敦的时候，我们去吃派和土豆泥。我很乐意，我很乐意。太棒了。
Great. Thanks, pal. You're welcome. David, thank you so, so much. Have a great rest of your night. Thank you very much. Off to the families. Oh, cheers, me too.
太好了。谢谢，伙计。不客气。大卫，非常非常感谢你。祝你余下的夜晚愉快。非常感谢。去陪家人了。哦，干杯，我也是。
And have fun at the premiere. Thank you. Yes, sir. Thank you, I will. Take care, bye. Bye, David. Off to the families. Oh, cheers, me too. And have fun at the premiere. Thank you. Yes, sir. Thank you, I will. Take care, bye. Bye, buddy. That was incredible. Also, I'm good for your birthday, Christmas.
首映式玩得开心。谢谢。好的，先生。谢谢，我会的。保重，再见。再见，大卫。去陪家人了。哦，干杯，我也是。首映式玩得开心。谢谢。好的，先生。谢谢，我会的。保重，再见。再见，伙计。那真是太不可思议了。另外，你的生日、圣诞节我都没问题。
That was incredible. Yeah, wow, I did not see that coming. Me neither. I was like, oh, I'm not gonna know who the soccer player, I'm not gonna know who the soccer player. When you kept saying, like, Will, you're gonna know, I'm like, what is he talking about? But you know, to our listeners out there, we...
那真是太不可思议了。是的，哇，我没预料到会这样。我也没预料到。我当时想，哦，我肯定不知道那个足球运动员是谁，我肯定不知道那个足球运动员是谁。当你一直说，威尔，你会知道的，我就想，他在说什么？但你知道，对我们的听众来说，我们……
We got Shani back on, like we got Shani again. But like, so to our listeners like me and Sean, we're not big soccer fans, but we make a commitment to you in the audience that if we're gonna bring somebody on that does something you have no idea about, they're gonna be charming, they're going to be uber famous, okay, and they're gonna walk you through it. They're gonna answer all your questions. And by the way, sometimes they're not gonna be any of those things.
我们请回了沙尼（Shani），我们又请到了沙尼。但是，对我们的听众来说，我和肖恩，我们不是铁杆足球迷，但我们向观众承诺，如果我们请来的人你们完全不了解，他们一定会很有魅力，超级出名，好吗，而且他们会带你们了解。他们会回答你们所有的问题。顺便说一句，有时候他们可能什么都不是。
Yeah, sometimes they're. Okay, and then we just won't air those episodes. What are you, a lawyer or something? We've got a can full of them. But JB, you know what was great about him, and you kinda hit it on the head, which is he was able to articulate exactly what we wanna know about him, right? Yes. So you ask him, and he what was great about him, and you kind of hit it on the head, which is he was able to articulate exactly what we want to know about him, right?
是的，有时候是这样。好吧，那我们就不播那些集数了。你是律师还是什么的？我们有一堆这样的存货。但是JB，你知道他最棒的地方是什么吗，你有点说中了，那就是他能够准确地表达出我们想了解他的什么，对吧？是的。所以你问他，他最棒的地方是，你有点说中了，那就是他能够准确地表达出我们想了解他的什么，对吧？
So you ask him, and he's so open, real, and I love that, and it's evident that he's, I think it's part of being English, so that he's very down to earth. And he's so charming. He's not over his skis, he's very in tune with his family, and he's just down to earth, so he can talk in a way that's very accessible.
所以你问他，他非常开放、真实，我喜欢这一点，而且很明显，我想这是英国人特质的一部分，他非常脚踏实地。他非常有魅力。他没有得意忘形，他非常关心他的家庭，他只是脚踏实地，所以他能以一种非常平易近人的方式交谈。
Yeah, that's why I'm like, well, how are you so mellow? Yeah, it's not, Sean, it's not hard. If you just smile a little bit, Sean. I know, I'm just like, hug, hug, hug. And just get out into the world, too. You know what I mean? He's a guy who's out doing shit. You're exhausted if you go to Larchmont.
是的，这就是为什么我心想，你怎么这么随和？是的，肖恩，这不难。如果你稍微笑一笑，肖恩。我知道，我只是想，拥抱，拥抱，拥抱。也要多去接触外面的世界。你知道我的意思吗？他是一个在外面做事的人。如果你去拉奇蒙特（Larchmont），你会精疲力竭的。
Like, what are you? You know it's so sad, that is true. It's fucking true. This guy's going all over the world. You know what's so sad? That is true. It's fucking true. This guy's going all over the world. You know what? He's getting into the world. He's out there, man. No, here's the other thing.
比如，你是什么？你知道这太可悲了，那是真的。真是该死的真实。这家伙走遍了世界。你知道什么最可悲吗？那是真的。真是该死的真实。这家伙走遍了世界。你知道吗？他正在融入世界。他在外面，伙计。不，还有一件事。
Every time you guys said MLS, I was like, ooh, real estate. I thought you were talking about real estate. Exactly, yeah. I got so excited about like. Right. Was he sending a listing? By the way, maybe we can.
每次你们说MLS，我就想，哦，房地产（MLS在美语中常指房源共享系统）。我以为你们在谈论房地产。没错，是的。我太兴奋了，比如。对。他在发房源吗？顺便说一句，也许我们可以。
Can I see photos? I'm so giddy at the thought of... I mean, I guess I'm now a Miami fan because I really like that. I think I'm a Miami fan. Even though Farrell's gonna be mad because he's an LAFC guy, we love Will a lot.
我能看照片吗？一想到……我就头晕。我的意思是，我想我现在是迈阿密队的球迷了，因为我真的很喜欢那个。我想我是迈阿密队的球迷。尽管法瑞尔会很生气，因为他是洛杉矶FC的球迷，但我们非常喜欢威尔。
We like the battle. And we like the battle. So we don't want to get in trouble with that. But right now, we want to help David. We're gonna help. Jürgen Klopp to Miami. I will fucking... Don't let him get in the tears again.
我们喜欢这种竞争。我们喜欢这种竞争。所以我们不想惹麻烦。但现在，我们要帮助大卫。我们要帮忙。尤尔根·克洛普（Jürgen Klopp）去迈阿密。我发誓……别让他又流泪了。
Well, if that happens though, Willie, then you'll have, well, but you'll be an LA FC fan, and then you'll be a Miami fan. Yes. So basically your fandom will be literally by... CROSSROAD! I was gonna say, you're gonna be so excited. Thank god we cut before that.
嗯，如果那样发生了，威利，那你就会，嗯，但你会成为洛杉矶FC的球迷，然后你又会成为迈阿密队的球迷。是的。所以基本上你的粉丝身份将完全取决于……十字路口！我本来想说，你会非常兴奋的。谢天谢地，我们在那之前剪掉了。
That was fucking rad. SmartLess. SmartLess. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjarff, Bennett Barbicoe, and Michael Granteri. SmartList If you like SmartList, you can listen early and ad free right now by joining Wondry Plus in the Wondry app or on Apple podcasts. Prime members can listen ad free on Amazon Music. Before you go, tell us about yourself by filling out a short survey at Wondry.com slash survey. What if your partner developed 21 new identities? Or you discovered that your friend who helped you through the darkest times was actually
那真是太棒了。SmartLess。SmartLess。SmartLess是由Rob Armjarff、Bennett Barbicoe和Michael Granteri 100%有机且手工制作的。SmartList 如果你喜欢SmartList，现在可以通过在Wondry应用程序或Apple播客上加入Wondry Plus来提前收听且无广告。Prime会员可以在Amazon Music上无广告收听。在你离开之前，请通过在Wondry.com/survey填写简短调查来告诉我们关于你的信息。如果你的伴侣发展出21个新身份会怎样？或者你发现那个在你最黑暗时期帮助你的朋友实际上是
a conniving con artist? Or what if you began seeing demons everywhere, inhabiting people around you, including your son? What would you do? I'm Whit Misseldine, the creator of This Is Actually Happening, a podcast that brings you extraordinary true stories of life-changing events, told by the people who lived them. In our newest season, you'll hear even more intimate first-person accounts of how regular people have overcome remarkable circumstances, like the man who went to jail for 17 years
一个阴险的骗子？或者如果你开始到处看到恶魔，占据你周围的人，包括你的儿子？你会怎么做？我是Whit Misseldine，《这真的在发生》（This Is Actually Happening）的创作者，这是一个为你带来改变人生的事件的非凡真实故事的播客，由亲历者讲述。在我们最新的季节里，你将听到更多关于普通人如何克服非凡境遇的亲密第一人称叙述，比如那个因为意外射杀试图救他的人而入狱17年的人，
for accidentally shooting the person who tried to save his life, to a close friend of the infamous scam artist, Amanda Riley. These haunting accounts sound like Hollywood movies, but I assure you, this is actually happening. Follow This Is Actually Happening on the Wondry app or wherever you get your podcasts, and you can listen to This Is Actually Happening ad-free on Wondry Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
到臭名昭著的诈骗艺术家阿曼达·莱利（Amanda Riley）的密友。这些令人难忘的叙述听起来像好莱坞电影，但我向你保证，这真的在发生。在Wondry应用程序或你获取播客的任何地方关注《这真的在发生》，你可以在Wondry Plus上无广告收听《这真的在发生》。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。